foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
oh ladies and gentlemen
people of the internet
retro rackets who are here
I'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
oh we're live we're actually live
I'm kidding I knew we were live what's
up guys how's everybody doing tonight
back to a regularly scheduled Tuesday
stream hope everybody had a
wonderful Thanksgiving
always goes too fast that that time off
always too fast
but on the positive side man we got lots
of uh
Hogwarts Legacy news to talk about
tonight
lots of Hogwarts Legacy news gaming news
in general I mean
busy busy busy times
all right my check camera check
there we go we are on we are live we are
rolling and we have a brand new edition
guys a brand new edition if you follow
me on Twitter or Instagram you already
saw this I'm gonna move the camera or
the mic back for just a second
so all of you can get a good look here
actually you know what hold on hold on I
can do I can do something even better
I don't want to break anything
let me let me put this to the test here
let me see if this will work okay
all right so I should be able to
oh yeah here we go here we go here we go
nope we're going the wrong way okay
there we go there we go
all right now see you gotta you gotta be
able to see that's the only bad part
about where I'm positioned is you guys
can't see the the top of the tree there
Sorting Hat as the tree topper
all right I'm gonna go away on the mic
for a second just so you guys can see
so we're gonna we're gonna work our way
all the way down
there you go
so we've got let's see we've got Hedwig
right there
we've got a Harry here we've got old
school Nintendo controller here
Dumbledore here we've got the Hogwarts
crest here we've got Harry flying on a
broomstick here this one might be my
favorite the little stack of the books
right there
if it was turned the other way you could
see the other ones and then let's see
who else do we got we got our boy Snape
right over here all dude we got two
dumbledores I didn't realize there were
two dumbledores Hermione over there
I think this is Ron down here yeah we
got Ron there so not complete just yet
my wife my wife did all this by the way
shout out to Mrs raconteur
um we're still looking for maybe like
some ribbon to go around it somewhere
maybe something for the bottom so it's
not just the
you know just the random stuff I have
lying around to make that look a little
better
but I'm liking it so far I'm liking it
all right let me put my camera back to
normal now there we go
and then eventually I need to update my
light right here too I just didn't have
enough time to do it before the stream
tonight
the uh
maybe change it to like some red or
green probably do green
actually you could do you could do both
you could do red and green on this one
all right so if I close out there okay
good camera stays live
so how's everybody doing man everybody
have a good Thanksgiving all my American
friends who celebrate
see who we got here hanging out tonight
let's see who is in the chat tonight I'm
gonna go all the way back up to the
beginning we got mark
oh oh by the way
the mods and I have been talking I was
like we've got to come up
with a name for our
group here you know
right as Elwyn gives five tier one
memberships let's go elwin thank you so
much if you guys just received a gifted
membership make sure you think Elwyn
there in the chat you just unlocked
access to all these fun Hogwarts themed
Emoji now we're gonna let John Cleese
take over for a couple minutes here I
keep meaning to change that
oh because we just get we just get in
this endless cycle you know
thank you so much Elwyn
so we got let's see Caroline got one of
the gifted memberships oh no and then
Nico just gifted five more and it looks
like our little icon is broken again for
some reason on the gifteds
we fixed that last time but it's messing
up again
and then we got in between there we got
a super chat from volte so volte thanks
so much for the super chat ah I'm stuck
in this super chat again
oh my goodness
someone help me volte thank you so much
and also shout out to Nico for the five
gifteds as well so five more people
getting a gifted membership right here
at the start of the Stream
so both Nico and elwin coincidentally
moderators uh both here and on the
discourse we were talking about we've
got to come up with a name you know
all all great communities online they
have a name
so I'm following this one out there as a
trial for now because I I want it to be
something that fits with raconteur but
also works with kind of like the World
of Harry Potter
but also something that can Outlast that
you know so once we move on from
Hogwarts Legacy and move on from
Wizarding World stuff it will still be
effective
so right now the one we're throwing out
is house raconteur
house raconteur so welcome new members
of house rack and tour congratulations
you just unlocked all the Emoji we
talked about and we also learned here
live during the stream that you also are
not subject to slow mode uh you get
discounted merch you get priority reply
to comments and special access to a a
community section and also I'm looking
at adding more tears so that might not
happen till next year but I've also been
thinking about I want to be able to give
you guys more stuff but I'm trying to
think of stuff that's like actually you
know worthwhile things you're going to
enjoy and then we had do we have another
five in there let's see
we did we got another five from our boy
noob
what is up Noob another five gifted
Noob thank you so much for those five
tier one memberships more members of
house rack and tour come on in guys come
on in welcome to house raconteur
our motto is oh we gotta we gotta come
up with a motto see it's like it fits
for Harry Potter but also that that goes
far beyond just the World of Harry
Potter
like House Targaryen House of the Dragon
there are all sorts of noble houses
throughout history
I like it I like it we'll see how we'll
see if it sticks
and then we got two more let's see were
they gift I'm not sure if they were gift
I think no these were not gifted uh Plum
Bob Kingdom renewing their membership on
a two-month streak and then Aletha May
another tier one membership uh the one
month streak right there and then volte
with another Super Chat coming in can't
stick around much girlfriend is in the
mood seems like a monthly thing just
wanted to send some love volte thank you
so much for showing the love show show
us the support for the girlfriend too
come on now come on
vaulty a relatively new member of the
channel or maybe volte maybe both he's
been lurking for a while and we just
didn't know about it
whatever the case may be volte thank you
so much for being here thank you for the
support
oh my
good stuff you guys good stuff all right
so
I think I caught everybody
now let me uh we want to shout out
everyone that's here so we got see this
is how this is how things get quickly
derailed
it's my fault it's me it's me not you I
promise it really is it's me
so we start off the stream normally
shouting out the people here and so the
people that are channel members
I always make sure it's known when
they're a channel members so now if
you're a member of housewrecking tour we
can say that as we're going through
instead so Mark turmine is here hanging
out member of House wrecking tour right
there Johnny boy is here in the house uh
sithra another member of House rack and
tour Mel is here fire T member of House
wrecking tour there wide is here we got
Elwyn of course we shouted L one out uh
oh man then we got a streak of channel
members right here we got Bradley Moon
Lily and sithri again soundtrack tabby
cat and Noob all members of house
wrecking tour right there uh volte here
in the hanging out in the chat as well
uh David also a member of House wrecking
tour we got Peter girai
Christy Jean Dyer moderator and member
of House tracking tour here as well
Sharon Cruz member of House wrecking
tour the broom closet witch
that's a great name right there that's a
great name I love it
uh we got nightbot and stream elements
oh man hopefully they don't hopefully we
don't see any battles there tonight
between the two I think I've got them to
stay in their Lane and not bother the
rest of us
but we'll see we're testing out nightbot
tonight on a trial run we'll see how it
goes stream elements the chat bot has
not been very responsive and as you guys
see the channel members the the pictures
broke and all of a sudden even though we
fixed on the live stream so stream
elements they're on thin ice right now
there's a lot of things I like about it
some some issues though too
uh we got Ultra Blue Jr here fandom
draws Nico uh both of those are members
of house rack and tour as well Jordan
Crawford house wrecking tour fetch Quest
gaming welcome thank you for stopping by
and being here tonight Bradley Roberts
pilot Joseph lowercase Logan what's up
my friend member of House wreck and tour
those three right there uh let's see we
already got Jordan and Noob and fandom
let's see Casey welcome back Casey
another member of House wreck and tour
there and we got Moon Lily member of
House wrecking tour uh we already said
Phantom draws I believe Mathis how's it
going Mathis wingardium levios sawawa
sawawa sawawa
don't know that one
don't know that one
let's see DJ Steph in the house sin
mermaid member of House raconteur insane
gaming Viper is here hanging out tonight
as well Shadow guided member of House
fracking tour Moon Lily Jason nagura
Ravenclaw and Dustin Quest hey Dustin
did you see I stole your Tweet or I
stole your comment I tweeted it out
I did give you credit though
Dustin another member of House Dragon
tour great great comment during the last
stream toward the end just kind of made
me lose my mind it was hilarious so I
had to tweet it out uh let's see Tom is
here in the house
who else do we have here the Blazing Red
Coat first time watching live
your vids have been making me so high
for Hogwarts Lacy let's go do plenty
more to come too appreciate the kind
words and glad you got to catch a live
stream here live stream's a totally
different vibe
it just like very quickly derails I'm
not kidding you guys I got I've got like
notes here tonight
we gotta we gotta stick to our outline
here all right and at the top and bold I
have do not get derailed by chat I'm
kidding I didn't write that but
we do we do have a lot of things to get
through tonight a lot of things to get
to Jagged wizard
house record tour member Let's see we
already got fire tea I believe halbery
is back with us again as well and Olimar
92 Olimar what's up I see in the
comments Olimar see you in the comments
on the video today tabby cat both of
those members of house wrecking tour
right there Caroline Draven oh you guys
got gifted memberships nice Brittany and
let's see who else got one
uh okay these people didn't get one but
now it just went back to regular chat
for some reason Antonio welcome how's it
going Antonio
fetch Quest gaming let's see Gabe got
one of the gifteds B Barbie our Shep one
of the gifteds
Professor Abbott with a gifted welcome
back Professor Abbott you are now a
member of House wrecking tour I feel
like I need a I need a sword or
something like like a scepter you are
now a member of House reckon tool
forever
so you shall be called oh I should get
one of my wands you guys that's what we
should use super Niche gifted
Ginny uh also known as damio one Chris
huff and puff welcome back Chris all of
those house tracking tour members right
there as well Mathis Jenna crin Alexia
house in the house yet again welcome
back house let's see Antonio got one of
the gifteds as well Michael with one of
the gifteds
and let's see we got Jenny there's
Christy again
okay this is perfect stream elements is
working in the chat it's doing what it's
supposed to be doing there that's
awesome uh Katie baby is here back with
us again let's see there's Moon Lily
Michael Sullivan Mathis
JP raven fire member of House wrecking
tour Malcolm also a member
and
it did the thing guys it did the thing
where it jumped up and skipped her oh my
gosh hallberry you're totally right we
need a house animal we need a house
animal all right there were some more
Super chats that came in I might also be
here to cause chaos in the chat that's
volte with another Super Chat and then
Noob not to be outdone coming in with a
super chat as well you know how I'm your
favorite Noob and all I think you should
hydrate
Noob always coming in clutch with the
hydration uh tonight
see if you guys can guess just from the
top
I always drink zero calories zero sugar
drinks so
I don't think that gives it away
I don't think just the top gives it away
and then also
a house coming in with a super chat
right after that house in the raconteur
house indeed
and then Magnus Carlson with another
Super Chat rolling ink guys thank you so
much with all the love and support on
the super chats to kind of you are you
the next Community host for the next
showcase
I am not Madness people keep asking I am
not
I have not been approached by Avalanche
about anything of the sword nor WB
I told you guy I told you guys what to
look for man if if I ever just like
ignore it or if I
if I'm like I can't say
but if I'm just straight up like no I
would not lie to you I would not
outright lie I just wouldn't say
just wouldn't say
so yeah
there you go that's it
Noob I I promise man it's not a lie it's
not a lie but Magnus thank you so much
for the donation
uh I mean
it would depend on the terms you know
like what like the timing and everything
but most likely I would I would love the
opportunity yeah it'd be awesome and who
knows if they're I mean who knows how
many more they're gonna do if they're
going to be able to stick to their plans
uh because I mean they clearly indicated
they're gonna do more or they want to do
more
and who knows if they'll even have
content creators at all of them
they they may choose to do another
similar thing without we just uh we
don't know yet we don't know I feel like
it's I mean it seems likely that they
would have more
but um
like even James talked about how
how long ago he filmed that right
so it's like
if they were gonna be doing more I feel
like now would be the time right to be
having people filming okay why is
nightbot getting people for spamming
we're gonna have to I'm gonna have to
look into that guys if you're if you're
getting kicked or welcome to Griffin
Victor nice try stop spamming caps oh
all caps I guess it's trying to get you
guys
apologies guys hopefully it doesn't time
you out or anything
um we just set up nightbot tonight so I
might admit I might have missed some of
the categories there so don't worry you
didn't do anything wrong it's probably
just catching Nico said it's catching
the all caps okay gotcha yeah
yo and then we just had fire tea coming
in with five gifted memberships also we
missed a Super Chat there from per
barthol thank you for the Super Chat
fire tea thank you for the gift of
memberships you were all now officially
members of house rack and tour uh oh and
I always forget Nico's gonna get onto me
for forgetting you also get a special
Discord role as well special Discord
role the prefect Discord role is what
we're calling it out might change it in
the future you know post Hogwarts Legacy
but right now it is the prefect role and
then we just had a hundred yo
a hundred SEK which looks like
translates to 10 US dollars per bartho
with another Super Chat I don't I'm not
seeing a message with that so if you're
trying to include a message I apologize
I'm not seeing it but thank you so much
for the for the donation for the Super
Chat
very much appreciated
raccoons in the chat
oh dude you guys are right we've got to
come up with like a coat of arms we
gotta have a a mascot for this
I wish I could show more of the chat in
this little box over here it's not
letting me slide it down anymore
love how many slytherins we got a lot of
slytherins
nice you guys thank you for the
memberships too
you love to see it that's I mean that's
that's the community in a nutshell guys
we have an outstanding Community here
and speaking of before I forget this
before I forget speaking of community
here let me pull up this real quick
all right so
if you guys have a Twitter I need you do
me a favor right now if you guys have a
Twitter
um because this is kind of stuff I want
our community to be about so uh Lex EA
oh no I'm botching this at Lex
eh Lex so how about we just spell it at
Lex
e-h-lex on Twitter
so uh Lex here I'm not even sure if
that's his name actually
so Lex here did some Channel designs for
us and actually you can just see he he
shared them he retweeted uh basically
everything in our merch store that is
somehow connected to Magic
in some way was designed by him he did a
phenomenal job he's a member of the
community I don't know if he's here
tonight but um he's always showing love
on Twitter and everything and recently
he posted something very
um very sad very unfortunate on Twitter
so let's see scrolling right back down
here so this was November 24th uh he
said my mom died on Monday and it's been
a really hard week I found little
enjoyment anything uh watching uh this
uh drag race BBC seeing my favorite win
smile for the first time
but guys as a member of this community
let's just go show him some love if you
have Twitter just go show him some love
um I know it's it's kind of it's like
awkward
you don't always know what to say but
this is the kind of stuff I want our
community to be about you know we gotta
lift people up and
he lost his mother you know which is is
not going to be easy for anybody to deal
with and I want him to I want him to
feel the love of our community if you
don't know what to say I mean I didn't I
didn't and this I mean this is all I
could say you know very sorry for your
loss you don't know what to say in those
situations but he's a member of our
community he's done some awesome work
for me so if you have a Twitter please
go show him some love there and uh you
know just try to help lift somebody up
that's that's really what I want us to
be about and you know if you've ever
been
regardless even if you're not somebody
who's
made designs for us I would like to
think that we would try and lift
everybody up in the same way so
um yeah just hate to Hate to start off
on a kind of a somber note there but as
a member of our community I just wanted
to make sure that we we showed him some
love on that
and some encouragement
yeah and if you guys have
Twitter it's no big deal he he pops in I
actually don't know uh there's a Twitter
right here
Lex
l-e-x e h l e x on Twitter and if you
want to go to the specific post it was
on November 24th
at uh about 6 58 PM but I guess that's
that's probably my time so
but yeah I'm not sure if he uh I know
he's I know he pops in and watch his
videos but I don't know if he's ever
commented or anything
because when I put out several months
back that I needed a graphic designer
which never do that by the way
never do that I got hit by so many
bought fake accounts it was ridiculous
but he rose to the top because he was
clearly someone who had watched our
videos and supported the channel so
um but yeah all these designs
if you go to
if you just go to retroecontour.com and
you click on merch right here
which we just got some new ones
so these like anything that said retro I
did but like this unforgivable curses
he did that design
just I mean I would never wear this
because it creeps me out I'm not a dark
arts kind of guy however when we did our
poll this was the top thing people
wanted an unforgivable curses
um merch more than anything else so I
said all right we're gonna do it so we
got a t-shirt in that one I love the
design though if I was totally gonna go
dark I would wear this uh he did that
one he also did all of these uh icons
right here you got the lion you got the
snake you got the eagle you've got the
badger and then he also did our order of
Merlin designs as well
which by the way this is uh this is kind
of like a weird Teespring flaw
it looks blurry when you go and look at
it on Teespring guys but if you it's it
doesn't show up that way when you
actually get the physical one so I don't
know why I did that but yeah so that's
um that's Lex if you guys are wondering
and this this irks me because I chose
the premium t for the T-shirt versions
of these the colors are slightly
different like see how that maroon and
that green are different from these two
I actually like the long sleeve much
better I feel like those are more
actually you know what I think I like
the Gryffindor long I mean the lion long
sleeve the snake long sleeve but then on
the eagle and the badger
the Badger's pretty much the same but I
definitely like the eagle
um
short sleeve right there better but yeah
I wish you could just do the same same
colors
anyway
uh oh nightbot working overtime let's go
ravenclawed Tyrell member of House
Racine tour and our ship as well that's
right that's right our Shep you got
gifted member nightbot is too strict oh
no
and we also got Let's see we got another
Super Chat from Casey Lawrence where are
y'all where are my mixed houses at I see
a lot of people who
say this online so if you guys don't
know what that is that's like when you
when you feel like you're kind of a
split between two Hogwarts houses Casey
says I'm a Slither puff so Slytherin and
Hubble bub very interesting combo right
there
very interesting and then we also got
Dustin with another 10 super chat
petition to name group the mods as the
grand Jewel raconteur's House of rack
and Tool
I'm loving it already dude I'm loving it
already and then we have let's see two
back to back oh no wait somebody gifted
again I missed uh I missed the gifted we
got raveical Tyrell with five gifted
memberships ready to call Tyrell thank
you so much for the five gifteds those
of you who see your name popping up over
there right now congratulations you just
got one of the gifted memberships
oh wait hold on nightbot is that one
teacher in high school that everyone
hates
them well the thing about nightbot is
they do make it pretty easy to uh
I'm just gonna pull it up in a separate
window here make sure I don't
don't show anything that I
did and give away like some super secret
code
okay wait Ultra Blue got timed out for
posting links even though it wasn't
actually a link
oh Victor got time okay this is good
though I can see all of the uh
oh I need okay I need I see which one I
need to turn off immediately the excess
caps all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
disable it
all right now it says it's disabled
let's make sure it's saved now I'm gonna
go back to my dashboard
Malcolm got timed out
Malcolm got signed up for saying thank
you I got one thank you so much Noob all
caps no Malcolm no you cannot thank
people in all caps actually let's go
crazy with the all caps just just go
crazy for a bit with the all caps guys
see if you get uh see if you get timed
out or not
let's see if uh if it works and it's
saved I'm not gonna see any comments
elwin you're probably just
L one is probably
um not subject to it anyway because
you're a mod okay there insane gaming
Viper got through Moon Lily got through
mail here we go the all caps party
nightbot has been put in their place
excellent excellent okay now the spam
the one there was one let's see who
posted um Victor said hi from Brazil
Victor sorry we missed that thank you
for being here and then I'm not sure why
that one got oh posting symbols
Jenny posting symbols nightbot come on
now you know we love our moats here
nightbot excess symbols
I'm sure I could tweak these later to
allow certain symbols but right now I'm
just gonna say
disabled
now I am going to leave the links when
on
just because that one can get a little
crazy but uh Ultra Blue uh Jr so what
happened with yours if you ever put a
period and then you don't get the space
after
all of these Bots just automatically
think it's a link so all Ultra Blue
posted was why did they not show them
off months ago a question to Katie I'm
guessing you guys were talking about the
uh companions
or not companions
so I'm gonna keep that one on so just
make sure you guys put the a space after
a period and you won't get flagged
for that one
Jay Rossi in the house Jason Hodges here
as well what's up guys
J rossienna Jason
and then I see Brittany there too so
we're officially calling if you're
members of the channel you are now
members of house raconteur
and I need to next time I'm gonna have
like my wand and
you are now members of house raccoon
tool congratulations
J Rossi Katie
um
it's uh J period I'm guessing J for his
first name and then Rossi I'm assuming
is the last name I could be wrong
not by night but I told you to stop
laughing
oh goodness
all right so let's see I'm I'm actually
Consulting my notes Here you guys think
I'm kidding
okay so we got
we got that taken care of oh yeah yeah
next thing so
the way that I normally do chat this is
a good this is a problem but it's a very
good problem to have it's a very very
good problem to have by the way if you
guys hit the like button uh when we get
to 100 likes we will do a special
we will do a random quote
from the Harry Potter series and we'll
let you guys guess live so right now
we're at 63 total likes let's get that
up to 100 and we'll do a uh we'll do a
little quote quiz with everybody
but yeah so good problem to have here's
the problem
I have I have a problem again it's me
not you it's me
I have a problem of wanting to of trying
to read every single comment
and our streams have been so hyped and
somebody somebody earlier I saw a post
about how the chat is zooming yeah yeah
welcome to the show
this is how it always is which is a
problem I love to have however I really
I think it's starting to kind of hurt
the streams a little bit because I'm
getting so far behind that I'm not able
to keep up with you guys
so what I'm gonna do instead
what the vast majority of streamers do
instead of scrolling back up I'm just
gonna look in the window that I have
here and I'm gonna stay on the most
recent so what this is going to result
in and you guys you might have to post
something twice or a third time if it's
something you really want me to see
however I'm also going to add us I'm
going to start adding a section to the
end of the stream I'm going to try to
set aside about half an hour or so where
you can submit questions because YouTube
has this really nice feature which I
only recently discovered where I can
open up like a separate box for you guys
to submit questions
and so then I'll just be able to pull up
the panel of all the questions and just
go through them one by one instead of
instead of trying to answer them
individually now sometimes if they still
pop up in the chat and it's like you
know the discussion's kind of lagging or
or if it's perfectly relevant I might
throw it out there but again it's more
me than you guys I'm just gonna have to
do a better job of staying on the most
recents and if I miss something from a
while back my apologies you guys can
always try and post it again we do have
slow mode on for non-members so that
just means you have to wait like 60
seconds the likes are going up quick
let's go yeah so the likes just help
other people find the stream looks like
we're up to I'm seeing 90 now almost
there 10 away guys 10 away
and then the other problem again this is
definitely me problem we keep getting
flagged for
um copywriting music
I think what happened last time my
Spotify playlist that I was on I had set
to only play from
royalty-free music however I think it
ran out
and then it just jumped to something
else oh so it's like I'm laying in bed
after the last stream the the YouTube
system is actually really quick at
detecting this too it's really quick I'm
laying in bed after the stream and I I
pull up my email and it's like copyright
violations
oh goodness you gotta be kidding me
and so I there's like there's like four
or five of them
so if you're ever anybody watching on
the replay Squad going back and watching
this
if you're ever wondering like what the
heck happened why is there just a weird
cut here or it just went silent for like
three minutes or something
or if the audio goes kind of wonky for a
bit
it's probably because we got caught for
the copyright
and I'm TR I'm trying to only play
non-copyrighted music it's super
frustrating
um but again that's something that
hopefully you guys won't have to worry
about
I just got to make sure that Spotify
plays from the correct playlists from
now on and see then this is the other
thing that happened we'll get to a song
like this one where I'm kind of like eh
I'm not really feeling this
and then I will skip the song okay now
let's see what it okay good we're still
on the same playlist we're still on the
same royalty royalty-free playlist
all right we got it we're good we're
good
done the like thing yo let's go
all right so
let me see what did we get to what do we
get to we are at 105 likes all right so
Harry Potter book quotes we're trying to
stick to book quotes you guys book
quotes and don't look it up that ruins
the fun if you look it up
so uh first thing you want to answer is
you want to answer the character who
said it in the Harry Potter series the
second part
is you get bonus points in our imaginary
list of points you get bonus points if
you can name the book
if you can name the book that it comes
from last time the vast majority of
people got the character
but missed the book
but missed the book
all right let's see here
oh that won't be too easy
and that one would be too easy too
that one would be way too hard
all right actually you know what I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go to this book I'm
gonna pick a specific book here
I'm gonna scroll back up I'm gonna
scroll down I'm gonna scroll all around
so you guys don't know where I'm looking
oh my gosh they're always
it's always like the same five
characters
okay this is a good one this is a good
one
this this one's tough this one's tough
I'll be impressed if anybody gets this
one
all right let me make sure I got the
correct book here
all right so here's the quote
I am a wizard not a baboon brandishing a
stick
I would definitely have missed this one
definitely have missed this one here it
is again I am a wizard not a baboon
brandishing a stick
we'll give you guys give you guys a
couple minutes on that one don't look it
up it ruins the fun
and there's also
there's kind of a curveball with this
one I'll tell you after after I reveal
it
laughs
oh goodness
Alexa says try saving the royalty-free
music to Spotify and then Loop the music
usually helps me with them playing music
ah okay see this is like the only time I
ever use Spotify
so
I have it all in a playlist so I think
somehow it like got outside of the
playlist because I thought wait maybe I
didn't I didn't have it on a loop that's
it or no wait is that enable repeat
I'm turning it on enable repeat one
I don't want it to repeat this song
though all right we'll see we'll see if
it repeats this song after because this
song's almost over
all right let's see we've got we've got
a
we've got a Dumbledore guess we got a
goblet of fire we got Flitwick book one
we've got Gandalf
sorry that one is incorrect we've got
Ron Weasley sounds like Malfoy we've got
a Sheamus from Alicia Percy McGonagall
Flitwick
we have to call Tyrell I'm only to book
one
sounds like something Hermione would say
McGonagall Flitwick to Sheamus in book
five Bradley says I think
Professor Flitwick says super Niche
Trevor book 10 Lupine book three
uh Flitwick says hi IQ Warrior don't
know which book getting a couple of flit
Wicks here
Bradley says definitely Flitwick to
Sheamus don't remember which book
and then JP raven fire getting to
getting to the true answer here and why
I said it's kind of a curveball
you're right it's when Flitwick made
Sheamus write the lines
so I will accept Flitwick or Sheamus as
a correct answer this list that I pulled
up gave it to Sheamus and said it was a
line written by Sheamus while in
detention
um but it was actually from Harry Potter
and the Half Blood Prince is the correct
answer
Harry Potter and the Half Blood Prince
yeah that was an obscure one so kind of
a curveball because it was more about
you know
riding the lines
yeah I'm gonna have to find a better
website for this ironically I clicked on
the exact same website that I clicked on
last time I was trying to find a
different one but
nicely done nicely done
to those of you who got that one right
that was a tough one that was a tough
one
just started them all over
oh yeah you got plenty of time you got
plenty of time
Johnny boy says oh yeah I'll fade her
first book
ordered a PS5 nice
I really sound like Dumbledore and the
Sorcerer's Stone video game
oh man wait why did that comment get
taken away
maybe uh maybe they recalled the comment
I don't know
all right so
we're moving right along we're moving
right along on our list we got that one
taken care of
and we talked about that one
all right next thing new video hit the
channel today
you guys definitely want to check this
one out this is my full deep dive video
into the
gameplay showcase
full deep dive I left
I limited it to 60 details honestly we
could have went way way more but it's
weird you know people love these kinds
of like details secrets you missed type
videos but I definitely feel like
there's a point of diminishing returns
and I don't know what that point is yet
so it's like there's a point where I
feel like people wouldn't click it's
like oh that's too many I'm not gonna
watch that like back when they did the
first gameplay
um state of play I did I think it was 55
things you may have missed that video
did really well so we'll see how this
one does bump it up to 60 but I feel
like if you get too much above 60
like I feel like if you get into 70 100
I feel like a hundred
I don't know 100 would be interesting
I'm curious to what you guys think
here's to what you guys think
do you feel like um
is there a point where you feel like
it's too much another thing I feel like
people look look at and this is I
definitely do this is the duration of
the video like this one clocks in at
over 21 minutes
over 21 minutes and I actually I mean
you guys know how I start videos I don't
have a lot of intro at all and birdie
bought every flavor listen to this here
are 60 Hogwarts Legacy details you may
have missed from the recent gameplay
showcase we'll start off our list in the
Hufflepuff I mean I'm right into it
so
there is no extra fluff in this video
we're we're straight in there
and still over 21 minutes so you know
it's a packed video I usually try and
hit around I feel like 15 is a good like
digestible number
I probably should have tried to get it
under 21.
we did get it just under 22 though uh
let's see we got Casey with a super chat
okay Casey ended up typing that in the
in a super chat instead Casey thank you
so much for the support retro really
sounds like Dumbledore in the Harry
Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone tooth
sorry to say 2021 2001 video game when
he welcomes people who join to become
members
oh man when his glass and his glasses
are also like
they look like 3D glasses or something
if it's the PC version
Oh and about time too
lowercase Logan with another Super Chat
hey retro on Tuesday my aunt had to go
to the hospital and the stream provided
a nice Escape for me and my young
cousins eased our anxiety thank you very
grateful to you and this community lower
case Logan dude thank you so much for
sharing that I how's everything with
your aunt is she
doing better out of the hospital
whatever you know however much you're
comfortable saying
but yeah very sorry to hear that and I'm
glad to hear that in some small way that
the stream was able to
to help with that
I always crack I cracked up at a comment
actually just before I went live I was
checking some of the comments on the
video today
and somebody said like please do more of
these and I was like okay you got to be
a new
you must be a new follower of the
channel
because we got quite a backlog
quite a backlog of Hogwarts Legacy
videos
let's see here I was watching a video
from like two months ago of a live where
I did Ollivander oh yeah ollivander's
probably my best one I'll just go ahead
and it's all downhill from Ollivander
definitely best impression there
all people asking about TVs
yeah you might be able to get some good
deals right now or I don't know they
might be over
usually I feel like for a while people
did a lot of retailers did like cyber
deals week
first it was Black Friday you know
everybody had to go out on just that day
then they turned into black Friday's
week well then we've got Cyber Monday
then it's like cyber week and now I feel
it's like all of November it's just
deals month
but yeah I did see that samria tiller
started uh
returning prices down
Chris says no I have autism Legacy is a
special interest I'll never get enough
nice see that's me no more than 60
somebody said
tabby cat I like the longer videos
more than 59 darn it Sharon I'm just one
over your list
so I guess Sharon can't watch the video
sorry Sharon
Alicia I would watch any amount
because I think Ben uh Benjamin snow did
one
he had he had a really long one on the
breakdown I watched all of it but I was
like I wonder how many people will
and then see there's also this balance
of like if people see it's a hundred and
the video is five minutes it's like okay
well that must not be very interesting
if it's five minutes to go through a
hundred things so yeah there's there's a
an interesting balance there
yeah this this would definitely be a
good time to get a
man my videos it looks like the quality
on this looks so much worse than
watching it in the probably because I
didn't do the 4K one because that just
takes way too long to export
a 4K
even a 4K capture a lot of people watch
it on mobile though so it's gonna look
fine on mobile
Logan said she's doing better now
nice nice happy to hear it
Alexa certain people I'll watch whole
videos
you expect a PhD podcast now top if it's
about the game don't worry make time
nice nice good to hear it
and then we got
a t wait why did that not pop up in my
little uh
hmm not sure how long ago you sent that
fire tea apologies if I missed it I
didn't know I could do this gonna ask
something here then have you ever seen
Harry Potter and the portrait
of what looked like a large pile of Ash
I feel like this is the start of a joke
have you ever seen the portrait of what
looked like
Harry Potter and the portrait of what
looked like a large pile of Ash
is this the start of a joke I haven't
seen it I don't think I've seen it
fire tea thank you for being a member
here though
and then we had uh Ray just subscribe to
the channel nice and then we've got Matt
with a super chat hey retro what's your
craziest Hogwarts Legacy prediction well
Matt first of all thank you so much for
the Super Chat and supporting the Stream
my craziest prediction
hmm
well I feel like my most crackpot theory
is that bathilda bagshots a Ravenclaw
companion
but I don't
it's a crackpot Theory it's not one like
that I'm fully backing
oh man I feel like I'm starting to get a
pretty good handle on
the mechanics of the of the game now
I said last week I feel like this the
gameplay Showcase Video I think gave us
more than any other look that we've seen
so far I feel like it really showed us
kind of the parameters of the game the
structure
that
not all of it but some of it
um
oh here this could be a fun one I don't
think there's a jump button
I think there's no jumping in Hogwarts
Legacy I think it'll be more like like
Zelda style uh like the old school Zelda
style or like how God of War handles it
you're gonna come to a gap and then you
just press a button to like leap across
you will not be able to like jump freely
that's my prediction
there you go that might be that might be
one of my craziest ones there
am I a Hogwarts Legacy tester no not a
tester just just somebody super excited
about the game Malcolm who's decided to
start making videos on it and things
kind of took off and I've been making
videos ever since about it that's it
that's it
and I love that so much hope we meet
bethilda like even if it's not a
companion I think it'd be awesome if we
met beild a bag shot at some point she's
definitely alive she's definitely around
uh most likely out of Hogwarts
most likely
so it would have to be something that
takes us outside of Hogwarts I mean when
they first started talking about the
field guide this is when my theory
started I was like dude this field guide
sounds like somebody's writing Hogwarts
of History so I was like what if we're
like on a quest with her where we're her
apprentice and we're helping her to
essentially write Hogwarts of History
foreign
wood final boss
oh man
I doubt that I doubt that
I feel like Chandler would not want to
be I don't feel like Chandler would want
to be in the game
it would be funny though you remember a
lot of older games like the devs would
use like their own names or the names of
their kids or family members for NPCs
and stuff so we know all the NPCs here
have names
so I think it'll be interesting if they
if any of them have like some of them
are clearly Wizarding World inspired but
other ones they could just be choosing
randomly
yeah if we go to godrick's hollow that's
right that's right Mathis if we go to
godrick's hollow that would be a good
opportunity Alicia I need I need a jump
button well it was something that Nico
we
um shout out for this video by the way
shout out to the Discord members
exclamation point Discord there in the
Stream if you guys aren't part of the
Discord yet but
um this this video here was a group
effort
a lot of people in the Discord you'll
see their names here go by at the end of
the video helped helped make this video
because they spotted a lot of things and
went and time stamped it for me and it
was one of the things that Nico
commented on Alicia I mean I'd already
kind of been thinking it because it's
like why wouldn't we have seen a jump at
some point in all the footage they've
they've shown us so far
but um gosh what was it Nico there was a
there was a moment where
oh I think it's just because of how
we're using X
and in most games the x button is what
you would use for jump
here though you're gonna have to be
using now to be fair you hold R2 and
then press X to do a spell that's how
you do it
but
if you're holding R2 then you would be
giving up your ability to jump if they
have it on there
it's like such a it's like such a weird
thing not to show if it's not in there
you know
foreign
oh my goodness high IQ Warrior you gotta
are you on Twitter
or in the Discord I need to see a
picture of that dude
I need to see a picture of that my PC I
got a tempered glass panel etched with
the Hogwarts Legacy logo that is sick
I need to see a picture of that if
you're on Twitter tweet it to me if not
um maybe in the Discord
you guys are saying nightbot is back
let's see what's nightbot doing now
oh my gosh Alita May got timed out for
posting symbols
oh wait no that's that's old
or no is that new
I don't know
I'm not seeing any other recent timeouts
though
oh my gosh this is cool you guys this is
cool
all right I don't think this is gonna
just making sure there's nothing on this
page I shouldn't be showing let me bring
this over
look at this you guys
oh people are gonna be vying for this
top chatter of the stream so far is Nico
and our top command so far is Discord
dude we should do something fun at the
end of each stream where we like I don't
know I could shout out the
the leading
oh he should no it's me what if it
changed in real time we just see it
immediately change over to uh
Alicia
now everybody's just gonna be spamming
try and beat Nico there
and I know Nico's happy that Discord is
the top comment as well
where's the top donator yo
that would be cool I don't think
nightbot had that one
Stefan nightbot needs to be renamed to
peeves
I can't be beaten
that would be a good name I think you
have to pay for the uh
oh no that was stream Labs I was looking
I've been looking at all the like the
bot options to see which one would be
best see I love the stream elements
overlays and how they have their
overlays set up
I do streamlabs before and previously
switched away from them for several
different reasons but
then the stream elements bot was giving
us a lot of time
dude I missed a Super Chat oh my
goodness Leisure not my apologies that
was almost four minutes ago uh do you
think Eleazar fig is related to Mrs fig
from Order of the Phoenix great question
Leisure not thank you so much for your
support of the channel and the 10 super
chat so it's possible
the reason I'm leaning toward
no is because of
the name the last name
Arabella fig spells hers with two G's
whereas Elias are fig from Hogwarts
Legacy spells it with 1G
so it's like okay if they really wanted
him to be related to Mrs fig why not
just make it exactly fig unless there's
gonna be some weird story reason for it
now throughout history even real world
history when it comes to last names
there are times that people
change their last name for whatever
reason
I don't know if this
Side Story here tangent tangent you guys
my grandmother told me this story years
ago
I need to ask her if this is true
I mean she wasn't like she wasn't joking
when she told me this so I assume it's
true but she said that her
um her maiden last name is Mathis
although we had a Mathis in here tonight
m-a-t-h-i-s however she said that her
father's last name was actually Matthews
but that
he couldn't fully read him right
and whenever he would sign things and
and he just started abbreviating he just
started making it short so instead of
writing out Matthews he just started
putting Mathis on everything
now in this day and age of course that
could never happen right because of all
the all the records you would have to
change it legally somewhere you would
have to have it officially changed but
back then I could totally see that
actually happening so he just like
instead of writing Matthews on things he
put Mathis on everything and then
eventually
her last name was Mathis
like that's what that is what her her
legal well not anymore she's she's
married now but her legal last name was
Mathis
so Mike is that really did he change it
legally or did he just start putting it
on all sorts of documents
that's a great question Alexis so um
Arabella fig of course we see that one
in the books with Eleazar fig they
actually mentioned him in a blog post as
well
they mentioned him in a blog post and
they spelled it with just one g
so I I think it was clearly intentional
now another possibility it could be
something like what I said like maybe
Arabella fig decided
because she was a squib she didn't feel
worthy to be I don't know a true fig or
something so she added on a g I don't
know
tabby cat with another Super Chat
rolling in there thank you so much for
the support tabby cat did the quill put
Nat side's name in the book or did she
just get into Hogwarts because her mom's
a teacher oh yeah so the uh book of
acceptance
Quill of admittance did I get that
backwards
so I don't think
we can look this up actually I don't
think it is limited to just
Hogwarts
I feel like it would flag every magical
individual
but I could be wrong
uh let's pause this
okay yeah so this is from all the way
back in 2015. Quill of acceptance book
of admittance all right
huh let's see oh this is actually not
too long and a small lock Tower never
visited by any student sits an ancient
book that has not been touched by human
hand since the four Founders placed it
there okay so it was the four founders
so that's Hogwarts Centric
uh stands a small silver ink pot from
this protrudes a long faded quill these
are the quill of acceptance book of
admits they constitute the only process
by which students are selected for
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry
um if anybody understands what powerful
monolithic magic causes this book and
quill to behave as they do nobody has
ever confessed to it
doubtle is because as Albus Dumbledore
once-sided saves the stabbed tedious
explanations to parents who are Furious
that their children have not been
selected for Hogwarts
now that's interesting
so that implies
that there are actually Wizarding
families who don't get in
the book and Quill's decision is final
and no child has ever been admitted
whose name has not first been inscribed
on the book's yellowing Pages well
there's your answer right there
there's your answer is that just because
NASA's Mom that's not the only reason
yeah there's the answer at the precise
moment that a child first exhibits signs
of Magic the quill which is believed to
have been taken from an augury floats up
so okay this right here I mean I feel
like that's worldwide
so even just because their name appears
in the book doesn't mean that they have
to attend Hogwarts however to go to
Hogwarts your name has to be in the book
I think
did you guys get that so just because
your name is in the book doesn't mean
they like force you to go to Hogwarts
obviously you you can take schooling
from home
um you can just choose not to go you can
go to another Wizarding school but for
hot but but to go there your name has to
be here
those who have observed the process
have enjoyed spending quiet hours in the
book and quills Tower hoping to catch
them in action agree that the quill
might be judged more lenient than the
book
a mere whiff of magic
suffices for the quill the book however
will often snap shut refusing to be
written upon until it receives
sufficiently dramatic evidence of
magical ability oh my goodness see now I
feel like we need the opening scene of
Hogwarts Legacy it needs to be the quill
is getting ready to write our name down
and the book snap shut
the book snaps shut
and the books like nope not allowing
this one until
whatever this big event happens before
Hogwarts Legacy this big assuming
something that happens with ancient
magic that lets us in then the book
opens the book is like oh my goodness
now we have to open up now they can
write their name
that's the very moment that Neville
Longbottom was born aquil attempted to
write his name was refused by the book
which snaps shut even the Midwife who
attended Alice Longbottom had failed to
notice that Neville managed to shift his
blankets more snugly over himself
moments after birth assuming that his
father had tucked the baby in more
securely
persistently missed signs of magic in
him and not until he was eight years old
uh his disappointed great aunts and
uncles except that he was truly a wizard
when he survived a fall that should have
killed him
interesting the book sternus has a
purpose it's track record in keeping
squibs out of Hogwarts is perfect
non-magic children born to witches and
wizards occasionally have some small
residual Aura of magic about them due to
their appearance
but once their parents magic has worn
off them it becomes clear that they will
never have the ability to perform spells
the Quill's sensitivity coupled with the
books
I can never say this word
implacability implacability
have never yet made a mistake
there you go
not the squibs
Bradley what's up welcome
do I think they've completed the game uh
yeah I think the game's pretty much done
I think all they're doing is polishing
I mean Boston even said it if you go
back
oh and that was even several months ago
too so in the interview when they
interviewed James
or not really interviewed but when James
was out there for this
let's see I think he said it was when
they did
the
Pond hogsby trailer
and Boston made the comment now just
because that's just one Dev commenting
but she made the comment of like I'd
rather be
um this was in his behind the scenes
video about how she would rather be
squashing bugs
dealing with all the bugs
getting the game bug free
so it's I mean it sounded like that was
her primary focus at this point doesn't
mean so yeah I mean they're definitely
not adding things at this point
I mean we honestly we could be about a
month
a month and some change away from
the uh the game going gold
honestly
yep exactly that Johnny Boy exactly that
getting getting rid of every bug
imaginable
I mean I've never done any kind of play
testing but I can I can imagine that
it's a very grueling process
I mean I don't know what what sorts of
tools they have that allow them to
I'm assuming you can't just test for
these things that's why they have play
testers who they essentially want them
to try and break the game you know go
places you're not supposed to go cast
spells on things you're not supposed to
be casting spells on try to get into
areas that you shouldn't be allowed into
basically attempt to break this game any
way you can
and they find bugs that way you know so
I'm assume I'm assuming it's combination
I assume they have some tools that are
sort of automated and then I assume
there are other things that they only
just discover by by playing
I can't imagine I can't imagine it's got
to be a super grueling process though
hot take we can play on the Quidditch
pitch and shoot quaffles in the Hoops we
just won't be able to participate in the
match
quidditch cutscene uh I'm gonna say yes
on the cutscene
I say yes on the cutscene but no on the
first one
all right let's get into the Hogwarts
Legacy news you're a wizard Harry
oh wait wait no before that before that
before that
we gotta do an unboxing
I have an unboxing
that I need to do I've had this for a
while
um and you know what while we're doing
that we're gonna let the new fall ASMR
play
oh no no you know what we're not I'm
gonna go full cam for this
[Music]
I have had this forever and well I
shouldn't say forever but I don't know a
couple weeks now
see if you guys can guess what it is it
is not it's not Hogwarts Legacy related
so don't see this box and get your hopes
up
it's a very big box hold on
oh my
let's all right position it over here a
little bit all right so give you guys a
look at it this way
and then
and you can see Target right there
Lego Hogwarts Castle no no no
yo Nico got it Nico got it I think I
probably did you cheat Nico did I
mention it to you already
I might have tweeted about it I can't
remember
all right let me get it out of the box
here
oh my goodness you know what I just
realized there's there's gonna be
something in this box that we could use
for the uh
you are now a member of House Dragon
tour
hold on hold on
oh my goodness you guys aren't going to
believe this
you really are not gonna believe this
in the box we have
another
why can't you not dude another box
oh but now this is like the official one
this is the official one okay shout out
to Target right here there's some great
packaging dude when it comes to uh
collection collectors editions of
anything people are very particular
right I mean you don't want that to show
up all been up and everything so I love
obviously the collector's edition itself
comes in a box
but then this comes in another box
because they know that people want to
make sure that this is not all been up
so I like this let's see it says single
unit case do not cut
that's exactly what I'm going to do
right now
oh dude and it's got like the big do not
sell
do not do not display or sell
for November 9th 2022. that takes me
back to the Harry Potter days man when
the books would arrive and they would
have those giant stamps like do not oh
my goodness it is thundering here
hopefully the street I don't even know
it was supposed to rain hopefully the
stream uh
stays up that was a really big sound of
thunder
we're going to get right to the opening
of the box and then the whole stream is
going to shut down but um
hopefully we're good
maybe it's just passing through
all right so
I think it's gonna maybe it's telling me
maybe I shouldn't cut on this one I'm
gonna cut on the other side
which I believe technically is the
bottom but maybe they want you to cut
there so you don't accidentally cut into
the box or something possibly
foreign
oh my god dude this
this packaging I have never seen
I gotta lift this up so you guys can see
this I might just need to move my chair
out of the way
look at this man it's got like these
separators in here
I don't know if this is Target or if
this is Sony but that is
that is some very careful packaging
there all right so I'm gonna sit it down
flip it over and then hopefully we can
finally get this out
there we go
much bigger than I expected I'm gonna
need to zoom out the camera so you guys
can see this a little better here
all right let's go here and yeah let's
Zoom you all the way oh well didn't
really help much did it
did not really help much
but then I think I can also do something
called
overhead mode
nope nope node overhead mode
sorry overhead mode didn't work
but yeah once you actually get it in
person packaging for a God right
and this uh so then they have this
plastic around the edge which is
actually pretty tight as well
foreign
it's hard to even cut through
retro proof I know it's like they don't
want me to
but I've had it sitting over here
I've been so preoccupied I wanted to
replay God of War 2018 before I started
Ragnarok
and replaying it has been an absolute
blast
I knew it was a good game the 2018 one
but when I first played it
I didn't quite feel like oh my goodness
this is one of the greatest games
ever I was like okay it's a good game
it's fun God of War nice reimagining
but on the replay man oh the game is so
good and it has so many
[Music]
let's try this
oh goodness
I should have waited another week for
the tree so we could sit this up there
oh there we go right there
right there on the arm so this is the
collector's edition they actually had
another one A Step Above This called the
uh yotinar Edition
but that one had some stuff that I would
probably never have a use for so I went
with this one instead
but um yeah replaying it
there were some areas there were entire
oh gosh what do they call them
not the king the Realms the different
Realms Realms that I didn't even go to
and play the first time so a funny thing
happened I thought I would just blow
through the story and be like all right
let's get to Ragnarok
but instead I've actually been taking my
time with it and I've been loving every
minute of it and I've been trying to
explore everything I think I'm gonna
have to I think I'm actually gonna go
after all the Valkyries too I've gotten
like I don't know three four of them so
far I'm pretty sure I'm at the point in
the story where I could go to the um
I could go to the end it like trigger
the end game but I'm just going around
collecting stuff like upgrading my armor
checking out all the Realms that I've
missed and I'm having a super fun time
all right so on the front here we've got
the blue God of War Ragnarok collectors
edition and then it says no game disc
biggest issue with this collector's
edition guys is that it's a
digital copy of the game and not the
physical
and then on the other side
oh we have a picture of all the contents
all right so
[Music]
hold on
foreign
[Music]
all this moving around I think I
accidentally like disconnected the mic
for a second
I disconnected the mic Weston what's up
dude
so jealous right now
Dustin says have not played a single God
of War Game rare I know I don't know I
feel like if you want to jump in though
the 2018 one
that's a great a great time to jump in
that's a great one to jump in on Jake
what is up man
member of House wrecking tour right
there dang it's already been three
months sorry I'm late it was at my
school's first home basketball game we
lost by six no allergies are killing me
dang sorry to hear that Jake
hope you feel better
and maybe maybe your basketball team
will get better
maybe they'll get better long season
long season
all right so there is a little
sticker right here
my whole mic just went out for a second
though
my whole mic just went out
yeah J Rossi so it is um it is made by
one of Sony's internal Studios
[Music]
it is uh every God of War is a property
it's like Mario with Nintendo they own
everything about it
so
um actually you know what they did bring
it to PC though
they did bring it to PC so it's not an
Xbox but you can play it on PC
zodiac what's up
yeah I did not and
I did not anticipate it being this large
like we just I just do not have enough
room here in my uh in my office area for
this all right so
there's yet another sticker here
and I wonder what would have triggered
my mic
yeah I kind of like bumped my desk and
the whole mic disconnected for a second
and another sticker over here
guess what another box
I'm not even kidding
all right note to self for the future
Hogwarts Legacy collector's unboxing
we are gonna need more space
we are gonna I'm gonna need to what I
need to do I think for the next one
is I just need to remove everything from
this little
uh these drawers right here and just
have it sitting over there because I am
I am just physically out of room here
I'm gonna have to sit this back down on
the floor hold on
and then we'll get out another box
[Music]
I wish you guys could see the other side
of my room now because it's just like
there's boxes all over the place
boxes everywhere
[Music]
oh you know what we could do this with
the camera though
this would help me out a lot
let me do this right here we're going to
move the uh
nope not that way
yes there we go
there we go
all right dude this is actually I mean
for box
that's pretty fun
that's pretty fun I like that
all right so we're gonna reach here
and the grand reveal
oh that's nice yeah so there's a lot of
these little uh
tapestries left behind
in the first game
and we see one right here as soon as you
open up
the collector's edition here
very nice
we almost lost it
I also have my drink over here I don't
want to spill
we'll move the drink over here this
disaster waiting to happen by the way
I'm fully expecting uh
either I don't know my mic I'm gonna
drop the mic
I'm gonna spill something on my keyboard
and then we have this little uh
compartment right here
oh wait or should I open this first hold
on hold on I think we're supposed to
open the top
come on
tell me there's another sticker nope
there it goes
that's just on there very securely
oh my gosh really secure
there we go
oh all right this is the weird part
though steel book
but no
physical copy of the game
really nice steelbook though
loving the design on the
that's the back
then we got the front right here
and let's see if the digital code is
inside no oh yeah it is it is
that's so weird though like there's
actually a
look they still oh wait hold on oh it's
like I do not need to uh
show my code on screen here
because then I would not have a copy of
the game
but um
still got like two spaces
for the disc
yeah I think the reason they had to do
this though which props to Hogwarts
Legacy for including the
collector or for including the hard copy
even though
the rest of the collectors edition is
not that great not a good value I should
say
not a good value but um they did include
a hard copy I think the reason they had
to do this though is because they're
selling some ps5s that are digital only
I feel like that's the big reason
all right and then we have a little
package here
and let's see we have one of these giant
and I mean giant
those absorber things
little packets there
and then we have
little bag here
dude this is cool
let's see what's inside oh this is the
dice
this is the dice
which I actually believe you could you
could uh you could use these in a in a
real game or something
I am not a Dungeons and Dragons player
so for any of you Dungeons and Dragons
folks you could probably let me know so
we have one that is kind of like a
pyramid shape here
let me see I want to put them where you
guys can
yeah there we go
where you guys can see them
and then we have this one
nope gotta get you right there
then we have
one that looks like this
those are pretty
could they be used for d d nice just
give the code away and get the physical
copy I yeah I've thought about doing
that Casey actually
if I if I do a giveaway it would
definitely be to someone here
[Music]
foreign
just like a cube
don't even open up the Hogwarts that's a
wound I know yeah
and then this one's kind of a much
larger one
all right so there's the dice
and then we have some figures
all right I've
no spoilers guys no spoilers I know the
figures are
significant to the story in some way
so we have the first figure here
um that might be Freya actually
[Music]
back you can see she's carrying a sword
and then this one
who could this be
freya's not a spoiler she's in the first
game and we know she's going to be the
second game
this one
also
someone with shorter hair but they also
have a sword
on the back there
uh this is not these they're not wood
but they're not cardboard either
I feel like these are kind of like a
probably like a but
high quality plastic these though man
I think these are plastic too but it's
like a really convincing
I mean it looks like wood these are yeah
they're pretty light these are pretty
light too let me hold it up to the
camera see how like
oh dude that actually Zooms in really
nicely on it there
really nicely
oh did we get did somebody else get
membership nice Johnny welcome to house
rack and tour
now I gotta I gotta hold this one closer
so you guys can see the
the detail on it there
really nice if you're into this this
kind of stuff I'm not huge on like
collectibles
but um I'll definitely have these these
displayed somewhere
all right so that's everything oh there
was one more there was one more dice in
here
one more
so it's a total of one two three four
five six seven
d d players you guys probably know much
more about this than I if you use all of
these or not
you probably have much more of an idea
all right so now let's put I'm gonna
slide this down put these back in here
and put this here we'll put the steel
book back up here too actually I might
keep the steelbook out so you guys can
uh
can see it
foreign
for the big one all right so we're gonna
open the door here
again we've already seen this come on
state stay open
stay open
and now we have
dude
dude this is so much bigger that it
looks on the
on all videos that I've seen of people
doing this all right this is this is the
main attraction here guys
all right do I pull out yeah I think we
need to pull out the whole
okay come on Hammer please don't fall
please don't fall out of there
all right I will sit you down now
we're good
oh my gosh dude
this is definitely getting a permanent
place
this is getting a permanent place in the
collection somewhere here
oh man
that was really loud
all right
a little piece of cardboard here at the
bottom
foreign
just some tape right around there
oh my gosh this is sick man this is sick
so try to get it I'm trying to get it so
you guys can see the
see the detail on there
what's it made out of yeah it's it's
plastic
it's like a high quality plastic pretty
sure
but for a I mean this I think in terms
of collector's edition like this is how
I would do it man this
all of this you get for for the
collectors it was 200.
it was 200 for the collectors and I mean
the game alone is 70.
the game alone is 70. so then for the uh
you're getting the hammer
you're getting the steel book here
you're getting whatever the uh the
digital content let's see
uh you get a theme you get the full game
for PS4 and PS5 with it so that's you
know uh Darkhorse digital mini art book
the official God of War soundtrack I
actually didn't know about that
um then some special armor
armor a more special armor and then you
get the dice and you get the um
the uh those little statues that we
opened
I think that's it let me make sure
yeah
yeah so there's there's everything
that it includes in the collectors
if you go for the yote narwin that one's
like 60 bucks more
and it includes if you're if you're a
vinyl person I would have went for the
uh I would win for that one
if you really are into vinyl records
because the vinyl is really really nice
really really nice
we gotta find a place for this
just like
just hang it on the wall there
would actually be kind of sick to be
honest but I might get tired of it
eventually I think we'll be able to we
might be able to sit it right here on
the on the table once we don't have the
tree up so you guys can see it
but now look at this look at this look
at this
until Hogwarts Legacy comes out we might
do we might have a wand but whenever we
have new members
and it's like
Chris hoffenpuff from this day forth you
are now a member of House raconteur
three times what's in the Hogwarts
Legacy Collector's Edition for a hundred
dollars less
I mean yeah
now I got a beat I gotta beat 2018 again
so I can uh jump into Ragnarok
and then one more we'll do one one final
look at the steel book there
so outrageously big right like on the
videos
that I've seen of people
it just looks small to me I don't know
why like every unboxing I looked at
it looked really small but here I mean
let's see let's do some like size
comparisons here
so if we compare this to oh here we go
this would be a good one a PlayStation
controller
PS5 controller like look I can't even
fit it entirely let me back up
there you go
it looks so heavy oh Ravenclaw Tyrell I
mean yeah only the worthy you know
only the Worthy
my wife finally asked me that box has
been sitting in my office for well ever
since Ragnarok came out
and she was like what is this box and
why do you just keep leaving it here I
said it's a collector edition thing I
need to unbox it and do a live stream
unbox it on a live stream
so
now I gotta clean up all the mess in
here you guys can't see the mess
thumbs down Draco what the heck dude
thumbs down
you got a thumbs down this my man
Dima right JP I'm not even gonna say it
again
not even gonna say the words again
all right that was fun guys that was fun
yeah so you know we'll have to do
I still have my Hogwarts Legacy
collectors on
pre-order but I've contemplated
I have contemplated that many times
I mean
it was just a hundred dollars cheaper
I would feel so much better about it I
still wouldn't feel great but like I
honestly like I legit think like just
the way my setup is here I'll be able to
hide that wire I know a lot of people
hate the wire on the floating wand thing
I'll be able to hide that wire very
easily
so that's not a huge deal for me I
actually think the floating wand in the
book is gonna look really slick sitting
right here
but it's just all the other stuff you
know
and the price that's that's my little
problem with it
the price is the biggest the biggest
issue
oh let me see what this uh
oh man yeah it is uh it is coming down
outside my house right now
so far so good I did just get a new
surge protector
so hopefully I don't have to put it to
the test here so early
yeah I think so Professor Baxter I think
so
um I'm hoping by like Christmas break
and all that when I'm off work for a few
days I'll be able to play it then
actually maybe even before then but I'm
just I'm so I'm taking my time with 2018
right now I'm going through collecting
I'm probably gonna go for the platinum
trophy actually that's when I'll move on
when I get the platinum trophy
book wand and the Kelpie robe I just
want the Rope
right dude isn't it crazy that you can't
uh
there's no other way to get the Kelpie
robe
no other way
oh dude
all right
it's time to get into the some get into
the some what what am I talking about I
can't speak uh it's time to get into the
Hogwarts Legacy news guys
because there has been a fair bit
I'm going to start with Twitter because
that will go the quickest
all right so if you guys I made a video
on this one but this hit right before
Thanksgiving so we didn't get to talk
about it on stream yet so so far they've
only been doing these little uh
character cards is kind of what I've
been calling them for companions
then they started calling them students
and we got omit
now they're also doing them for
professors and so we got the first
um not our first look but our first time
seeing her full name Dina heckett I
think it's Dinah
I think traditionally Dina is spelled
with no h so I've been saying Dinah we
did get uh Chandler wood clarified on
the last name it is pronounced heckit
which I thought that would probably be
the case since they knocked off the e
still I think you guys are right about
all the the references probably being to
the
the Greek goddess hekate hecatee
couple different pronunciations I've
seen for that one
and then we also got this little uh
descriptor here the stern but likable
Professor heckett takes her teaching
responsibilities quite seriously after a
successful career with the ministry of
magic during which she is rumored to
have spent time in the department of
mysteries she retired to become
hogwarts's defense against the dark arts
Professor though she is happy to be at
Hogwarts some believe her Hands-On
teaching method satiates an innate
desire for action
sounds like uh when I first heard it I
said this sounds a lot like Moody
this sounds a lot like a female version
of Mad Eye Moody which I am totally here
for
all right then in addition to that one
they dropped on November 28th Professor
Abraham Ronan now we already knew about
him he is our charms Professor head of
Slytherin house as well which a lot of
us picked on picked up on early early
when we saw these little uh
oh and the other thing we got on heckit
is that she's Ravenclaw so at the top
she had the little Eagle Crest up there
so even though they don't outright say
the house in the description you can
know the house by looking at at this
part up here so he's Slytherin we
already knew that uh also he is head of
Slytherin house that had been previously
confirmed as well
and then we got some additional
information on him with the character
card right here jovial and lighthearted
with a Perpetual twinkle in his eye
Professor Ronan considers his students
uh friendships and extracurricular
activities to be just as important as
the subject of charms itself
so this seems like a character I mean he
like really wants to bond with you you
know in response having been tutored by
a rather austere
austere
I've seen that word many times I don't
know if I'm pronouncing it correctly
feathers what's up welcome feathers
oh yeah I think Professor heckett would
win in a duel let's wait let's do
I think so
um uh tutor by a rather austere father
before and during his years at Hogwarts
he developed a passion for games of all
forms particularly gobstones I feel like
they're just taunting us at this point
he allegedly met his wife during an
especially Lively gobstones tournament
to the Delight of most of his students
his unorthodox teaching style often
incorporates gameplay so I think that
little scene that we see with uh our
character going outside like the
extracurriculars and he's standing right
there so that could be what they're
referring to there with uh the games
and so we've been getting these pretty
consistently now
and then they also revealed
let's see here
crosswand's dueling Club as long as you
followed the gameplay showcase that one
wasn't really anything new there
and then omit of course and then heck it
and then we're getting ready to talk
about this one right here
um oh yeah and then this one's real
quick too
Game Awards
oh this is a good poll question this is
a good poll question I'm gonna put this
in the poll right now
all right so guys if you're in the if
you're in the chat get ready you're
gonna see a poll question pop up soon so
Hogwarts Legacy is nominated
for most anticipated game actually let's
pull that up too
game awards 2022
yeah
nine days till the show coming up fast
all right and then let's look at
uh you can go and vote now by the way
Hogwarts Legacy is up for a nomination
so game awards airs live and free on
Thursday December 8th at 7 30 Eastern
Time 4 30 Pacific
uh show airs across all major digital
social and gaming platforms around the
world
all right now our nominees
where is it where's where is it
foreign
most anticipated
there's the competition
there's the competition and I feel like
I know how our poll is going to go but
really think about this guys really
think about this look at the competition
and then think how these are selected
which I'm pretty sure is this entirely a
vote only category
that I don't know does anybody in the
chat know is it purely based on fan
voting or is there another panel because
that that could be a factor as well so
do you think Hogwarts Legacy will win
most
anticipated game at the game
awards yes or no
might have misspelled anticipated
nope I didn't got it
Alex said there's a panel interesting
okay so I don't think it's just another
panel of 100 people
so it's like how much does the voting
count toward it right jury let's see if
they have anything here
nominations from the game awards are
selecting
nominations for the game awards are
selecting by a voting jury
I think they mean selected by a voting
jury of over 100 leading media and
influencer Outlets across the globe FAQ
and rules
the award process
okay nominees who cares it's already
nominated how are winner selected
winners are determined by a blended vote
between the voting jury
oh come on 90 percent
and public fan voting 10 percent fans
can vote for their favorite games on the
game awards.com and on our Discord
server in China fans can vote on the
winners via Billy Billy Billy Bali Bali
not sure fan voting closes on Wednesday
December 7th so you got about a week
left
so do they actually reveal
I wonder if they actually reveal the fan
voting too
why don't fans 100 select the winners
uh I don't think it'll win then
hahaha
I don't think it'll win
if it was only fan voting
then that would be very interesting I
wonder if anybody in chat knows do they
reveal
the um fan votes no matter what I hope
they do
I'd love to see the fan voting
would love to see the fan voting and
they also gave us a new screenshot so if
you just got home from work today and
you haven't seen this yet it's new
totally new screenshot right here
which quitotropes
on the Slytherin here we've got the
fountain here over here on the left uh
we can see I think this uh
I think it's a fish right here
and then we've got eagle
Badger snake and I'm guessing lion over
there
nice screenshot though nice screenshot
there from Hogwarts Legacy
and I'll go back here so let's go back
to the competition now
oh wait the award process
see what they say oh that's what we
already read
yeah they definitely have a typo right
there I keep reading that to make sure
nominations for the game awards are
selecting by a voting jury yeah should
be are selected
come on Keeley
all right so there was what they're up
against Final Fantasy Resident Evil 4
star field and then Legend of Zelda
tears of the Kingdom
Resident Evil 4.
one of my favorite games ever but guys
come on
you've made so many times
so here's their description for most
anticipated recognizing an announced
game that has demonstrably Illustrated
potential to push the gaming medium
forward okay Resident Evil 4.
absolutely not like for its time yes
Final Fantasy admittedly I know very
little about that one I know very little
about that one at all and what what
they're planning to do like I don't know
if there are any big change ups for it
obviously tears of the Kingdom
I feel like is the front runner
but uh it's important to note tears of
the kingdom was nominated last year lost
out to Eldon ring
I feel like the top three
like my gut is top three are Hogwarts
star field and tears of the Kingdom I
think Hogwarts Legacy will win the fan
voting
I think they will I was talking with uh
some people on Twitter lamerack I think
is how you say it another Hogwarts
Legacy content creator
lamwrack was saying he thinks they'll
win
Hogwarts Legacy
and this is even before I knew that
there was a panel the panel definitely
changes things but starting out even
just fan voting alone I thought it would
be close between tears of the kingdom
and Hogwarts Legacy
here's the thing which he was pointing
out the Wizarding World is huge right
definitely bigger than Zelda
but in terms of the gaming industry
which are the main people looking at
this
I feel like Zelda has the edge for sure
I mean Zelda's got a history of giving
delivering some of the best games of all
time
um generally you know what you're going
to get going into a Zelda game whereas
with Potter the Potter games
been a bit of a mixed bag right
now globally though worldwide
the Harry Potter as a franchise yes it's
gonna have but how many of those people
are going to sign up to vote right
because you have to you have to sign in
on the website and you have to vote
all that being considered I do think
Hogwarts Legacy will win the fan voting
I really hope that they reveal the
results of the fan voting
goodness sign into YouTube what
hopefully you guys can still see me
tiny dude sometimes
there are some things I really love
about OBS and then sometimes it just
does
some very strange things and this is one
of those times
it's trying to tell me that I'm not
logged in on my own chat
oh my gosh open the YouTube app on your
phone
come on come on Google yes it's me
I know I know it's for security purposes
and
come on come on you can do it
all right now I should just be able to
click on chat again
no oh now I'm getting like I'm getting
Echo we do not want that
okay there we are
kind of see the chat now
bruh
I should have never clicked on this
I was just trying to vote in my own poll
relax
Johnny I would vote for Zelda if not for
legacy see I also think
all right let me try to be objective
here
let me try to be objective like I
already said Resident Evil 4 one of my
favorite games ever made it's not most
anticipated we played it played it many
times out
star field
oh dude you know what
I could see Starfield winning and you
know why I could see Starfield winning
so tears of the kingdom is a sequel
and I don't think people will I don't
think people are expecting that it's
gonna do very much to push the gaming
medium forward
which is kind of weird that they're
using that criteria for most anticipated
game
like I almost feel like I almost feel
like most anticipated should be purely
fan voting
I feel like that one should be purely
fan voting
because most anticipated isn't that
about
people like who are gonna buy the games
I don't know I bet because of the with
this being the criteria
I feel like Starfield gets the edge over
both Hogwarts and Zelda because
I feel like they're gonna say it's
pushing it's doing more to push the
gaming media forward we've already seen
what tears of the Kingdom's doing we've
already seen that been been done they're
just Nintendo's gonna take the formula
with breath of the wild they're gonna
iterate on it it will no doubt be
amazing very likely will be a better
game than star field my guess I think
it'll score better even though I think
starfield's gonna be
shaping up to be a I I'm I'm actually
excited about all three of those to be
fair
star field is shaping up to be a very
good game as well I feel like tears of
the Kingdom will Edge it out though
in terms of the the final quality of the
game
uh Jay Rossi first new IP from Bethesda
in 25 years right I mean bethesda's got
a long history of innovating in the game
industry
and then we have Hogwarts which is
an incredibly hyped game that all of us
here are obviously incredibly excited
about right
oh but man now here's another
possibility
that said they have a panel of of 100
and that I guess they just cast a
straight vote
here's a possibility
what if you get a situation where people
are
Starfield and tears of the Kingdom kind
of split the votes between the um
the industry folks I could see that
happening
but the fact that the fan but if the fan
voting was like 50 percent
I'd give Hogwarts a much better chance
would give it a much better chance but
the fact that it's only 10 I didn't
realize it was only 10 percent
no starfield's gonna be so buggy
probably so
probably so all right let me I'm gonna
catch up with some of the comments here
see what you guys think
Ravenclaw Tyrell fans alone I think we'd
have it yeah I think so too
foreign
Starfield is supposed to be bethesda's
big bounce back after Fallout 76 and
makes Fallout 4. that's true too they've
had kind of a
they've had a couple misses lately
oh some people just got in yeah
look what we inboxed
dude I'm just gonna be like
I'm gonna be using this so much on
stream
Final Fantasy has a incredibly huge
following cat dad very true
dude globally
Final Fantasy might be bigger than Zelda
oh is that controversial
is that controversial Final Fantasy
bigger than Zelda
see and my perception is always skewed
because Nintendo man like Nintendo just
has that
you know love them or hate them
sometimes love them and hate them
it's it's almost like Disney it's like
they just they have these iconic
characters that very few other
companies can have you know
very few other companies
but Final Fantasy is very big globally
and it also has the advantage of being
multi-platform
see that I admit there like I don't know
much about that one I'm kind of ignorant
on what I have no idea what the preview
coverages look like cat dad you make a
good point that could be
Final Fantasy could be up there too
depending on like I don't know what all
they've shown in terms of like how much
it seems like they are going to push the
gaming medium forward
like why is that the criteria for most
anticipated game
so yeah I don't think Hogwarts Legacy
will win if that's the criteria
because like let's think what what do we
see there now not you guys because
obviously we we're gonna vote it to be
our number one
but if you're like the shoes of gaming
industry
whatever who who knows who all's on this
panel I don't know if it's people that
making the games like what have we seen
that would make us think that it is
pushing the gaming medium forward I feel
like it's a big step for Avalanche
that's for sure
really really big step for Avalanche
and let's be clear to even be nominated
is a very good honor for sure they had
somewhere let's see if uh
let's see there was a spot that said
something about like how the nominees
were chosen
let's go back home and then it was the
uh like the FAQ
yeah FAQ
how are nominees okay so nominees
chosen by internet okay so the jury
of over 100
okay so it's the same voting jury over
100 Global so Global that's another key
part here it's Global media and
influencer Outlet selected for their
history of critical video game
evaluation
specialized juries also convene for
other categories including Esports
accessibility and best adaptation that's
good
so it was in fact
um this this panel
that helped choose the nominations
game awards producer Jeff Keeley is not
a member of the jury and does not vote
on the nominees
each voting Outlet completes a
confidential unranked ballot based on
the collective and diverse opinion of
its entire editorial staff listing out
his top five choices in each category
ballots are tabulated in the five games
that appear on the most ballots are put
forth as nominees in the event of a tie
six or more nominees will be announced
in a category
so I mean to even be selected
that's a good sign
that's a good sign
yeah I really hope they reveal the fan
voting too because I think that would be
fascinating to see
I feel like I never watch this stuff you
guys I never watch I just like checked
the next day and see who won
um
but I feel like I remember that they
used to show here are the results of our
fan voting
and then they say the winner
so I feel like even if Hogwarts Legacy
could just win in the fan voting
that would be pretty big
that would be pretty big
yes that's true as well Gabe not all
Harry Potter fans are gamers
wording seems geared for Starfield to
win I I kind of feel the same way
most anticipated should be popular vote
no man's Skyrim
Starfield is basically an additional
story for No Man's sky
Timothy ninja I'm pretty sure I voted
tears the kingdom but I can't remember
hey at least you're honest at least
you're honest
I mean let's be real we can enjoy you
can enjoy all these games
cat had not seen anything about this
Final Fantasy either feather Starfield
is PC and Xbox
JP grew up Nintendo playing Final
Fantasy hook me became a fan
oh Chris says uh oh it just oh my gosh
why does it keep doing that
Final Fantasy greater than Legend of
Zelda says JP
now in terms of game quality
I gotta go with Zelda I gotta go with
Zelda
but I do I have enjoyed some of the
final fantasies
original kid says Hogwarts Legacy will
have it
Chris doesn't feel like it does have a
shot only because it's often said it's
game we've been waiting for since we
were kids
yeah true
if it was only fan voting or if it was
only even 50 fan voting
Starfield has more similarities to
Oblivion than Skyrim ooh interesting I'm
a huge fan of Skyrim I never even played
the others wish we had a list of the
judges right cat dad
that would help us figure out a lot
a Hufflepuff squid that's a good point
what could set Hogwarts Legacy apart is
how it's bringing more people to gaming
that haven't been interested previously
yeah and I don't know see like I'm I am
so deep in the Hogwarts Legacy bubble
that I don't even know like what things
are like in the mainstream so to speak
the mainstream games industry
to the point of I don't know that people
get that
I don't know that the outside the
mainstream industry gets
how many new people that we could bring
to gaming through this who are who are
seeing this and being like Oh my gosh I
love these books I always dreamed of
having a game like this and now they're
making it
yeah that's a that's a really good point
uh Johnny I will play Starfield but
gonna vote for legacy yeah I'll probably
I'll probably play
Starfield Zelda for sure and I might
play I I might play this Hogwarts game
you guys
I might play it
Gabe I'm super excited for Hogwarts
Legacy tears the kingdom is my most
anticipated 600 plus hours on breath of
water oh my gosh I mean there's nothing
wrong with that right there's nothing
wrong with that
and another part of that is you don't
know like you don't know how good
Hogwarts Legacy is gonna be we know
we're excited for it
with Zelda you got a pretty good idea of
how good that game's gonna be
[Music]
pretty good idea
he had Dustin there are a lot of good
games
lots of good games uh I'm gonna go with
Gryffindor Chad that's my house
original kid I have a friend on the
inside
can't say much Hogwarts Legacy will win
trust me
we'll see we'll see
oh a Skyrim stream that'd be fun
that would be fun it's on um
it's on PlayStation Plus
all right
let's shift gears a bit guys
good discussion good discussion
Steven says I'm hyped for Hogwarts
Legacy Starfield equally with Zelda just
to take behind
foreign
Zelda
oh dude they need to announce a new
Switch
he to announce a new one
all right so our poll 68 percent
118 votes say Hogwarts Legacy will win
32 said no
interesting interesting I figured it
would go that way
Chris still haven't beaten breath of the
wild oh it's it's good it's good
for sure
I just wish we could get a new Switch so
it'll be on a better frame rate and look
better
uh Sky Laura says as a gamer that
follows other streamers they don't get
it without in most cases that's kind of
what I was thinking yeah
um no original kid no online mode
why are you asking me you said you got
the inside scoop
oh you were talking about game awards
though I got you I got you now they I
mean they've said time and time again
because I think that's something they
wanted to get out in front of because
they knew people were asking for it
now in the future
we'll see
we'll see depending on how how people
are Professor Baxter you've never played
a Zelda game in your life
wow
I mean it depends what kind of the kind
of games you like too
I mean if you're if you're interested in
Hogwarts Legacy though I feel like you
would love Zelda
love Zelda it's such a they're just so
the gameplay the world like
just the action it's all done so well
the puzzles
JP voted yes for wishful thinking
foreign
late what I thought you were here
earlier Jason
not yet Ravenclaw Tyrell and I'll tell
you it largely depends on
what happens with Early Access
and what I mean is
like if I get a review copy or not
so the question was if you guys missed
it Ravenclaw Tyrell asked if I've
decided whether I'm going to be
streaming on the 7th February 7th that
is when Hogwarts Legacy comes out
I have not decided because I want to
wait to see if we are going to get early
copies or not
and I don't know I don't know I've I've
I've gotten some early copies for very
you know small indie games
um but it's kind of a new thing for me
right this whole uh
game coverage thing
so I don't know I don't know how it
works with WB like how willingly they
will give them out or not uh the reason
being Raven called Tyrell so if we get
early copies
I think I'll almost certainly stream on
the seventh
it depends on how early we get them
because
if if we don't get early copies though
then I don't think I'll be able to
stream it that day because I'm gonna
have to be
I'm gonna have to get through that game
quickly because what's gonna happen a
lot of people will get early copies and
their reviews will go up
at an embargoed time that will be before
the release
and so I hope you know I hope that a lot
of us who have been covering the game
will be fortunate enough to get an early
copy
to where we can review the game and
do I could do more than review the game
I can get a lot of stuff ready
beforehand
for that for those first couple days
because it's just gonna be
it's gonna be so much content you guys
it's gonna be crazy and I'm not just
talking from me
I'm not just talking for me it's gonna
be so much content
and
if I could like if I got imagine if we
got it two weeks early
if I got the game two weeks early then
you don't have to rush I get so much
content batched and ready to go
then when the seventh hits I'm ready to
talk about the game with you guys we can
go live I don't have to worry about
getting spoiled on anything I can replay
through the game
um but yeah so I mean and I don't know
when I'll know the answer to that really
I'm definitely gonna take some time off
of work though for sure
definitely gonna take time off of work
all right we'll keep uh talking and
answering questions as well but I'm
gonna go ahead and let this ASMR play
and I'm actually going to mute my music
and I'm going to crank up
the sound of this because I want us to
hear the the sounds of the game so this
lasts about 20 minutes we can just keep
chatting as this is playing as well but
um let me know what you guys liked about
this I think this is my favorite ASMR so
far
I think this is my favorite one man
and I'll just say yet again if anyone
from Avalanche is watching photo mode
please
photo mode
we gotta have a photo mode in Hogwarts
Legacy because I want to see like I want
to I want to get a screenshot of like
that right there
and be able to set that as my wallpaper
a 4K screenshot from my PS5 which I'm
pretty sure yeah these are in 4k
and to be able to use that
oh look at the you got the night sky in
the background
so where is it I mean is this hogsmeade
you guys think
these look like little I mean these look
like little houses not shops
maybe this is kind of just the
surrounding area
I haven't watched this through in like I
haven't done a deep dive on this yet at
all so I've watched it but I kind of
just uh
skimmed through everything instead of
watching it all
oh and we got a flu flame right there
yeah I don't think it's hogsmeade either
toadstools pumpkins leaves love the
ambience agreed
yes we got a flu flame so it's
definitely a place that we can fast
travel to
yeah I mean these look like little homes
almost makes me think of the burrow
which we're in a completely different
the outskirts of hogsmeade some kind of
Village
Johnny mentioned this a lot already oh
sorry Johnny if I missed if I missed it
um wanted to make sure I saw it the
broom teacher that seemed when she has
first showed
there's a green Welsh underneath on the
ground you think that's a you think
that's a dragon
I can't remember if I thought it was a
thestral or a drag yeah and then we get
the shot of Hogwarts right there off to
the left I definitely caught that but I
can't remember if we thought if I
thought it was um
if I thought it was a dragon or if I
thought it was a thestral
are they gonna be Muggles always thought
Hogwarts was the only hidden place maybe
Hogs me too
yeah I would say hogsmeade is hidden too
you would think
I just can't wait to see I mean the
castle alone
the castle alone is going to have so
many
secrets to find
what I want to know and we we get a we
got an idea in our head of how big the
castle is going to be based on you know
what we've seen in previous games
but then the outside
like how big is that we saw the scene in
the gameplay showcase where Alan said
everything you see you can go to
like how big is that like how far around
the castle when do we hit the invisible
wall
Jay Park you caught a stream you did
indeed welcome Jay Park
yo Shadow when you're having a baby like
the week before
two months paternity leave let's go
let's go Congratulations by the way on
the little one
is that your your first second third
more more than three
are they gonna be Muggles
I guess it depends on how far we can go
outside the castle
dude
is that the little toadstools that we're
hearing now I think it is
I'll be quiet for a second so you guys
can hear it
oh and we about to get creepy too
it's about to get creepy in here as well
those spider webs
yeah it's the little toadstools
it's almost morgue's creepy seeing this
all of this
seeing this all of this
sometimes man when you've been streaming
for two hours and 20 minutes you start
you start saying strange things
dude this is so creepy it's almost more
eerie seeing it in the day that's what I
was trying to say
I mean if we saw it at night with the
Flames flickering which we we've already
seen a little bit of it but see it in
the day
and then what the heck is going on up
here
dude
there we go get the little
get the little toadstools there I bet
we're gonna be able to gather these for
you I think they're ingredients for
something
and then there's there's more dude
there's more
like why are the spiders just
taking over
what a just an adjust position right
there of having the toe stools and then
the
what I assume are humans in the
background oh this might be my favorite
shot
that might be my favorite shot like I
just just I want to be in that field
like walking along this little pathway
up to the castle
you got the pumpkins over here on the
right like that shot right there oh man
I'd be spending so much time in photo
mode
so much time in photo mode
number eight Johnny oh my goodness
it's a dragon for sure totally been
against try wizard tournament but I
caught some things that made me think it
might actually show up ah
the fact that it was so close to the
Quidditch Stadium
I don't think it'll be Triwizard I stick
by that now could there be some sort of
fun little challenges that involve a
dragon yeah I could see that
I could see that for sure all right now
the lighting of my my in-room lighting
is messing with this over here
it's like I'm having to light it right
into my
oh my gosh you guys
I need to make a video of all my
outtakes at some point everything sounds
at least I hope it sounds all nice and
Polished once the video is actually post
oh man if you guys could only hear the
outtake sometimes I'll have to say a
single like
Clause of a sentence not even a full
sentence sometimes a single Clause of
sentence multiple times because I'm
I just can't get it out correctly
so what I'm trying to say here is the
lighting in my room
anything that's dark like in this corner
because I've got the big light shining I
mean it makes this hard to see so we've
got like uh like some mining equipment
over here
and then this looks like they they've
set up for something like they're
drilling over here digging
you're a wizard Harry
Skyline says those homes are pretty far
east of hogsmeade seems like an isolated
neighborhood or cul-de-sac as wife wants
a wizard would call it nice
Jason in the hospital now with your
newest baby congratulations Jason to you
as well that's awesome
all right I think we've seen a similar
shot to this one before
no Jordan I just saw your correction no
Muggles or very few yeah that's that's
kind of how I'm leaning too
nice your third Shadow and that's
awesome and then somebody said it's
their eighth I don't know if they they
mean your eighth child eight children
incredible
incredible congrats on that
oh I like that question the fountain in
the central room of the school has a
secret area underneath it
I mean
why not you know
they definitely called attention to it
in the uh in the Showcase oh is that a
little uh Brazier down there
it kind of dims the screen when I hover
my mouse so I'm gonna move it away so
you guys can see but
and then we see a little door right over
there
foreign
beverage oh yeah I did I did never tell
you guys what the beverage was but
just water
just water
black cherry tonight
should have stopped at seven Johnny
don't let your kids hear you say that
don't let your kids hear you say that
or your wife probably or your wife may
agree I don't know
I don't know
guess raspberry close very close
still wondering how our Patronus will
play in this
I don't think they're gonna have them
no inside info or anything
it's kind of a gut feel I feel like they
would have announced that if they were
gonna have them
I feel like instead if we encounter any
Dementors or or or or we have like some
special ancient magic Patronus
where everybody's is the same
that's my guess
I definitely don't think they're gonna
pull them all from Pottermore
will be insanely amazing if they did and
very disappointing for those of us who
have cats for our Patronus
while some of you have freaking dragons
so yeah I'd be a little upset
but it would be very cool on behalf of
avalanche
whatever what if Merlin is the Patronus
all right this scene right here we've
got interesting that there's this little
like flag here I wonder if that's a
marker for something
foreign
then we have the little Stones right
here
yet another area man I would just love
to be
walking through this taking photos
Johnny we're stopping after this one
high IQ Warrior
um
secret bosses in dungeons when you have
specific items in inventory or did
something else earlier in open world
wait I may be reading this wrong secret
bosses and dungeons when you have
specific items in inventory
I'm not sure what you're saying there
at least you're not dragging Patrol
right Timothy Ninja
cover your ears leash or not cover your
ears but um
all the people that got the dragon
Patronus you know what I think I think
they cheated on the quiz
I'm just gonna say it I'm just gonna say
it I think they looked up the answers
first
and I think they chose
the ones that would get them a dragon
that's what I think happened
oh Rob The Wiz and go ninja go sorry not
sure what you said that got your comment
we're trying out nightbot tonight so
don't get mad don't take offense it may
have been a uh
if you ever don't put a space after a
period it thinks that
doesn't look like anything was
oh my goodness we have a new top chatter
we have a new top chatter Nico you have
been dethroned
ladies and gentlemen
our new top chatter Chris
hop and pop
yo new top chatter
pay to win dragon
Griffin yeah Griffin's a good win that's
true's cool too
and I saw somebody saying they don't
like
um
or that they like their cat
oh my goodness Neil with the hummingbird
Patronus game what's up Neil
Mel got the Alchemy see I mean
and I keep getting tortoiseshell cat
nothing against cats you guys the
regulars of the stream already know
nothing against cats but I'm highly
allergic to them my my body my physical
design of my body is just designed not
to like cats I'm sorry I I shouldn't say
not like I'm designed not to be around
cats I love I actually like cats I would
have a cat if not for
my severe allergies regulars of the
stream you guys already know
you guys already know I shared my story
one time about we were at a friend's
house and they actually it wasn't even
because of allergies just because of how
many people were in the house foot
traffic and everything they put their
cats in another room
and uh
just like being in the house where the
cat was like with all the cat hair
that alone
set me off my eyes were itching like
crazy Elwood Elwood's spam in the chat
Nico might have had something to take
care of
he might have had to step away for a bit
but yeah so so the dragon is supposed to
be incredibly
incredibly rare
and
I see people all the time talking about
their dragon Patronus
and I'm just like well they're not so
rare then
why do half of you have the track of
Patronus not half of you just
random Reddit posts and stuff like that
maybe it's the other people or so just
like annoyed that they don't post but
all the dragon people are really excited
so they're gonna be loud about it
it's a Patronus though not a real cat
true true I mean that's that's a good
point Hannah it could be a cat that I
could actually bond with then you know
and I don't have to worry about any of
the allergy side effects
but why couldn't it be like a big cat
like a tiger or something
or a lion
how about a lion
I also think
the Patronus quiz is one of the like the
most
bizarre ones like I don't know how to
it's supposed to be that's the one where
it's supposed to be gut feel right we
did this live on stream a few several
streams ago
all right then we have another shot this
one is definitely that's hogsmeade right
you guys know I've told you guys some
terrible directions
wife wants a wizard that's where you
want to go for all your map positioning
directional videos somebody in the
comments today was like retro I really
want you to do a
video on the ASMR and break down the
position of everything
and I'm like I appreciate you I'm so
glad you love the channel
but I am not your guy for that I am not
anything with like position and
direction
no I'm I'm terrible at it inevitably
would get something wrong
and I think that's why like there's
there's a certain group of fans who
freak out about
a freak out in a good way like just go
crazy over these maps and stuff
which I wife once a wizard has made a
couple maps and then some people in the
uh
uh there's a Harry Potter disc Hogwarts
I can see Discord and maybe on the
Reddit too some people made these Maps
which are all like
very elaborately done and they've done a
great job on them and I'm just like
okay
all right I just want to get in there
and explore
so for the people that are excited about
seeing the map
I'm excited for you you know wife wants
a Wizards gonna be having a video
breaking this down
you know that he will
North hogsmeade okay this is Hogs me to
the left could be North Hogs me so
people are saying
all right all right so I'm not you know
McGonagall has a cat Patronus
it's a good point do you guys remember
is it official that
do your Patronus and your
your animages form
do they always match
I'm trying to think here
obviously we know that James
well we don't know what James Patronus
was we know Harry's was a stag
paddyfoot says yes
they match
Timothy ninja I think lupines did right
not always but mostly says Alicia
yeah exactly Britney you know where I
was going next so that means you're
telling me we're gonna have all these
Dragon anime Jive running around
I think the lore says that cats dogs
horses are common because they were
domesticated by humans and they have
formed a bond ah interesting
it can change depending on the caster
because like Snape's wasn't always a doe
right
Neil you're telling me to be a
hummingbird dude a hummingbird would
actually be a pretty cool Patronus
I mean I mean uh animages
that would actually be kind of cool
for an animages
Tonks has changed too
right right right right right
Dumbledore's yeah definitely a phoenix
Chris you got the hummingbird too
that's right you guys the patronuses can
absolutely change
oh so the always line that was that's a
good point but that was more in
reference to
him saying that he still loved her so
when when Dumbledore saw that he cast
the dose his Patronus that was
Dumbledore's indication like oh you
still have these feelings for her
then he dropped the always
and then we get another look at this
little village here
see I'm not even gonna try to like
break down where this is because I'd be
terrible at it
but this looks different these these
definitely look
they are not the same as the ones we saw
in the first part
oh my goodness like how many of these
little things outside
oh I think I want to watch that last
scene
I want to watch this one again
and then we'll let the whole thing play
through again
Draco don't want to be Rune sport is
yours a rune sport
a big enough event in your life can
change your Patronus falling in love is
a big event yeah
I agree JP
Patronus can change animages can't that
sounds right
ah the last scene is leading up to that
first Village but at a later hour
gotcha gotcha or the first one that we
saw was
yeah that one is at night this so this
one's during the day
all right we've got let's see
I kind of waited till the end of the
stream to do this let's see if we
actually have I don't know how many
people will take advantage of this
because I'm I've been doing better about
staying up to date on chat but I am
going to start uh no not a poll
if you guys have any questions about
about the game about gaming about
keep it PG
not questions about anything keep a PG
um
let me
questions
and then I'm going to start q a submit
them here so you should see a little
pop-up
that shows up in the top of your chat
box
if you want to send in any questions hit
that
and you can type them there
I feel like this has been flowing much
better I don't know how it's built for
you guys hopefully I know some people
already talked about me missing their
comments
my apologies for that
my apologies but I feel like in terms of
the Stream flow I haven't been having to
go back as much and I haven't been so
far behind I've been staying pretty so
for those of you who have joined late I
talked about this in the beginning this
is something I need to do a better job
on is
staying more up to date on the current
comments that means I may miss some
things
but I'm going to focus on the current
ones and if you guys have something
really important you could just post it
a couple times which somebody did
earlier
and I finally saw it but then I want to
have this part at the end of the stream
maybe the last half an hour or so where
if people do have questions we can still
set a time for that all right so we got
Chris with the first question here Chris
huff and puff do you think we will get
the next showcase December 6th oh okay
this is a fun one
and I'm going to let the ASMR play
through again because it's just so
pleasant and wonderful
my wife's asking if I fed our dog yes I
did
all right so let's look at the calendar
here
December 6 feels oh that feels a little
early
but
we know from before that they
pre-recorded they pre-recorded the last
one
pretty far in advance
so it could have actually already been
recorded
and they just haven't
um
decided to release it yet
all right so let's see here
December 6th is a Tuesday
and obviously around the holidays things
get crazy which they they posted the
ASMR actually on Thanksgiving Day
now here's another important thing to
remember they're not going to do it too
close to Christmas or New Year's all we
just saw did you guys see that there was
a lock over here
I just looked up and caught it watch the
little glint of the
oh there it was I'm gonna rewind it a
bit more watch right here in this area
there it is there it is the little
Shimmer
because they're definitely gonna want
people to live stream it hopefully all
I'm asking Avalanche WB give us more
than a day's notice please
although I don't know what I could have
done to get out of the last one it just
fell on a really bad day for me I had
too many other things to do
um so they did they will not have it on
Christmas Eve they will not have it on
Christmas day they will not have it on
New Year's Eve they will not have it on
New Year's Day I don't even I think
they'll stay away from those entire
weeks I mean that is a time when just
I don't know how it is in other
countries but businesses across the U.S
pretty much from like the and kids are
out of school colleges are out like the
last two weeks of December
and really like that first
week of January things are are generally
pretty quiet so I
I do think they'll stay away from that
in terms of a live stream now will they
release some some fun things like
hopefully they do an ASMR on Christmas
that would be so nice so nice if we get
the winter ASMR like on Christmas Eve
Christmas Day somewhere in there
because once January hits guys I mean
we're almost there we're like we're
right on the verge at that point so
December 6th
I'm gonna say the next week
I'm gonna say the week of December 12th
that's my guess for the next one
and then if they wanted to do a third
this is all purely guesswork by the way
you guys people keep asking if I'm the
next guest I am not
I'm not or at least I haven't been
approached at this point let me clarify
I haven't been approached
by anyone at Avalanche or WB
so this is purely a guess for me
I would guess like the week of uh
December 12th
and then for the next one if they do a
third because it is set up nicely if
they wanted to do one each month
they could hit December
so like that December 12th time frame
and then like January 9th that week
or the week of January 16th it's kind of
like that final or I don't know maybe
they would want to wait till even closer
to launch like
what if you did like January 24th that'd
be right about two weeks out that's kind
of like a final big push for the game
so yeah I could definitely see them
doing two more
it's just a matter of the timing of it
because the fact that we had
expecto goes he he recorded that so far
in advance which who knows people it may
have already been recorded
it may have already been recorded and we
have no idea yo Dylan what is up my
friend hope everybody's having a great
stream hashtag replay Squad hashtag 69
days
that's right we are officially under 70
days at this point until the release of
Early Access Dylan fellow moderator and
also
a member
of house raconteur
Dylan thank you so much for your support
on the channel
and your support of the Stream
my favorite color is blue
okay nice I like these rapid fires can
we see your Westie
normally she's in here with me but my
mom just got here before I went live on
stream and anytime there's a guest here
she's like she wants to be close to the
guest
so she's out there with them tonight or
I would totally
show you are there any good discords so
Phil I think we've got a pretty good
Discord Nico's probably already posted
it but if he has an exclamation point
Discord in the chat we'll get you the
link to it uh also James expecto go has
a phenomenal Discord as well
and then
um I know the official
Hogwarts Legacy Discord it has some
active members pretty active members as
well there's somebody uh from there I
chat with on Twitter a lot
who um he's part of their
all of like the Deep dive stuff
and they do a lot over there
Dustin when you host the next gameplay
showcase will you finally tell us when
you sign the NDA
oh goodness I mean yeah I would tell you
if if that were to happen I would tell
you
do you think they'll do any DLCs and
would it would go ninja says would it
work maybe is what you meant to say
there I 100 think there will be DLCs
I shouldn't say 100 99 percent
I think they want to do them
I think they absolutely want to do them
um if you're asking what I think would
work I would say I would say story DLC
stuff to do in the summer like for
whatever reason our character they could
come up with a good story reason that we
end up hanging out over the summer at
Hogwarts maybe it's not as populated
with students but maybe they could do a
couple more locations that we could go
out
like maybe you could have like like I
think I still hold out hope that ask man
is going to be in the main game
however if it's not let's say there
could be like an Azkaban DLC so there's
a big mission that you have to do with a
lot of things happening in Azkaban but
then you're still coming back to
Hogwarts and maybe there's some story
reason that a couple professors and you
know a few of your friends stay behind
to help you something like that but then
that would be kind of weird if you're
just walking around the castle with
nobody
it's just like all the ghosts
and peeves
Jordan if you were the community host
for one what would you want to show off
oh now that okay that's something I can
answer
and I would oh let's see here
okay
anything to do
with
wand the choosing of your wand
wand customization wand upgrading is it
in the game to what extent anything with
that I wouldn't want to show much with
story stuff and this is just not me
personally but just in general I don't
feel like they need to show a ton of
story stuff I feel like the little
tidbits like they're doing are much
better
and I also don't want them to show away
show Too Many secrets that are going to
give most of the game away
I don't want them to do that either
but little things like that like if they
actually showed us the one lore stuff I
think would be really cool to see like
we know that it's gonna bring over if
you have the Wizarding World it's going
to bring that over but what does that
look like in game you know
I can't wait to see all the models of
the wands that they have that they've
taken from The Wizarding World and put
in the game
that would be fun that would be fun to
talk about anything to do with that but
plenty more plenty more of other things
too
difference between levioso and
Wingardium Leviosa
Trent
so glad you asked us I just found this
out because I was researching it in a
video recently so they're from like the
same family of spells
but levioso is much more kind of like a
Leva Corpus
which kind of hung held people up by
their ankle but
um levioso is like they're just kind of
suspended in midair
Wingardium Leviosa gives the Caster the
ability to move the object once it's
lifted
I never knew this
and levioso I don't know if that one
even appears in the main line book
series
at least by name I don't know you guys
can correct me if I'm wrong on that in
the chat
but yeah there's a difference people in
the first video where I mentioned
levioso I got a lot of even though I
said in the video like I'm not talking
about Wingardium Leviosa I still got
comments being like it's actually
oh so like no
not this time it's not
foreign
most excited about oh I missed one hold
on do you think we will receive a big
reveal for Christmas to keep us excited
I'm gonna say if you feel like the asmrs
are big reveals yes
I feel like they've got two big things
left
I feel like they've got two big things
left
and I think it's a gameplay showcase
don't think they're gonna show anything
at game awards I'd love to be wrong
I'd love to be wrong
um but maybe two more gameplay showcases
and then like the other little things
like the ASMR stuff in between
that's what I'm thinking right now
which class am I most excited about uh
like gut reaction is defense against the
dark arts but if we we don't even have
it confirmed if Transfiguration is going
to be a class we can take I hope it is
because I think that could be really
cool if I could have a Patronus and
Hogwarts Legacy would you use the one
you currently have oh I would absolutely
pick a different one I would absolutely
pick a different one Alexis um
I would probably choose dolphin like as
much as I would want to choose the uh
the Dragon
it feels like it's cheating a little bit
there are some quizzes I've taken for
the Patronus where I've gotten dolphin
others I get a tortoiseshell cat
but if I could pick between those two I
would choose dolphin
do you think anyone major will die
oh interesting Theory I think we'll see
a Headmaster die and then black takes
over after his death uh I definitely
think there will be a death in the game
yes
January is going to be so long because
we'll be right there Jordan this is
supposed to be for questions
do you think there'll be different Brew
models
yes
I do we know there's that store in
hogsmeade quality quidditch supplies
even though we can't play Quidditch we
know that store is there
do you think there will be any season
specific okay hold on let me back up
though if not Draco
we know
because we're gonna have to use them for
trials that's what's making me hold back
because then it wouldn't be fair right
because you just if you get a super
overpowered broom then you can easily
win the trials but if you have the
underpowered broom you're not gonna be
able to win
unless it's somehow they find a way to
make level the playing field make it
skill based maybe the person you're
racing has the same broom I'm gonna
stick with yes though I'm gonna stick
with yes I think there will be any
season-specific quests
say no or say so Neil I'm not sure I'm
gonna say yes
and I think actually I think they pretty
much confirmed that the way that Alan
was talking
he knew in the gameplay showcase he
talked about how there's been a lot of
discussion around the time how classes
are going to work and he said that
everything is very narrative based and
he even mentioned I think he talked
about chapters
so I think it's going to be free roaming
Within
chapters within Seasons so in that
regard yeah I think there will
definitely be missions that are
on Seasons only
favorite spell from The Wizarding World
oh my gosh
like the most practical in a real world
sense
probably accio
I would use that all of the time
all the time
and like in our world today or if
there's anything that can make me fly
which I don't think there's a spell for
that
if there was anything that could make me
fly or teleport
I would choose that one I would choose
like apparate apparate's got to be at
the top of the list but
I don't know I mean I guess that I guess
apparate is a spell but it's kind of
so apparate number one and then accio
would be number two
how do I think the pensive will work um
no I don't think it'll be anything too
crazy I think it'll work pretty similar
to how we've seen in the books and I
think it'll just show us events from the
past that are going to be significant to
the story
possibly to do with something to do with
the ancient magic almost certainly
Nico do you think if our main character
goes down the dark path that will affect
how our companions act in battle as well
well Nats I act more dark if we are will
Seb be good more good if we are
honestly previously I would have said no
but Alan's answer
in the Showcase about our choices will
have some impact we don't know how much
and Chandler even kind of jumped in and
said but some of them are just going to
be you just be mean to a kid and that's
it like nothing really happens
but then other ones will actually
influence things even as important as
the final game
I'm still leaning toward no Nico but I
I'm closer to a maybe now than I
probably was before
said this in one of your videos do I
think there will be Quidditch
and or Wizard Chest DLC
Mr Moe
I don't I don't
I know that will upset a lot of people I
think
if they're gonna do DLC I think they
would stick within the framework that
they've made for this game which would
be
narrative based
something with a story
some sort of new piece to the story
because I feel like if you look at what
the vast majority of people want I feel
like that would be the the path that
people would choose
quidditch is almost big enough to have
its own separate Game Wizards chess I'll
I'll throw out a maybe on that one that
one's just like so low hanging fruit
though I mean you already have the rules
all you have to do is basically put in
some animations for the pieces to fight
right and that's it
I still like early on I thought they
were going to add a multiplayer online
mode in the vein of what goes to
tsushima did but I was saying that on a
lot of videos and Chandler pretty
quickly shot that down
so I think if they did that it would be
a surprise it would be a big surprise
for sure
what exactly is the function of a rubber
duck
well
I have to get back to you on that how
will flying on a broom be different than
flying on a beast
oh good question
I feel like the beasts might be faster
or I don't know would a broom be faster
I feel like the brooms will be more like
tight control maybe it's like maybe it's
like uh if you were driving a motorcycle
versus driving a car
yeah I hadn't even thought about that
we'll emit write down our Legacy
I think a mitt will have a role to play
in recording
events of the story yes
do you think there's an actual Ravenclaw
companion I do not I do not I think I
think Amit is the companion but I don't
think he's a companion like Seb natsai
and Poppy I think it's a little bit
different and I think they're moving
away from that term
companion and instead going with like
relationships I think we'll be able to
customize wands or brooms yeah I think I
think some at least some customization I
think so that's been such a big question
and a big fan request I don't think I
don't I'll say this though Casey I don't
think it will go as far as fans want it
to go I think it will be very kind of
limited tweaks on both of them
curious about how I will approach my
gameplay Explorer first and then tackle
missions or will I do one Mission at a
time and explore as you go along
so
normally Moon Lily the way I play open
world games
I do tackle missions of the story
but if there's some sort of side quest
or if there's something that I get super
interested in I'll go and do it
that's exactly how I'm playing God of
War right now now it also depends on how
I have to play the game like when we get
it if I get it early or not
because if I if and how early I get if I
get it early then I hopefully won't have
to rush through as much and so I can
just take my time and enjoy the story
I think the Ravenclaw companion will
introduce us to ancient magic or Ann
Merlin
Leisure not asks
uh no
nope I think someone else
probably fig
ured seaweed what a name love it do you
think there will be different wonk or
choices other than the three main cores
we are familiar with well they affect
GamePlayer combat drastically
I'm gonna say no when affecting combat
drastically I think they might have a
slight stat
tweak
but I don't think it'll be drastic if
they do it I think it's just my guess is
that it's purely cosmetic and the major
one course how many do they have on
Wizarding World because I think however
many they have there is what they'll
have for the game
do you think there will be oh that's the
one I just read
uh Christopher puff Merlin
I think I mean we already know Merlin's
in the game like in terms of the puzzles
we know Merlin is in the game from that
standpoint
so is he gonna play a huge part in the
story
I'm gonna say
is James watching right now
I'm gonna say not a huge role in the
story
but I do think it will be a side thing
that's my guess do you think the
Ravenclaw companion oh yeah I read that
one all right nice guys thank you so
much for the questions I'm gonna go
ahead and end the Q a
and then I will go back to the regular
chat
feathers no feather's gonna clip that
aren't you
Merlin's been said three times James has
been summoned
oh and I sorry believe you're not I
missed that question yes that was in the
list too how do I think the PC controls
will compare to ps5s well for sure
you'll be able to just plug in a
controller if you want but I'm I'm
probably a bad person to ask that
question because I don't do a lot of PC
gaming
I would say that I mean I would say the
PC controls will be will be fine I think
they'll be
and obviously when it comes to PC it's
just pretty much infinitely customizable
so whatever you don't like you can
change
I feel like the right click will be like
the part that I can't figure out about
PC is the spell
selection
because the way it works on the
controller is you hold R2
so I for sure think left click will be
like the basic shot
left click would be the basic shot
and then you're probably going to hold
the right but the right click
and then press a certain key
to fire off those uh four slottable
spells would be my guess
right click will be R2
there you go I got it
Nico does a lot more PC gaming I trust
what Nico thinks on that
wait what did yogg ask
Ed I saw
y'all that's a great question I'm glad I
caught that and went back so we
interviewed James two streams ago uh if
you guys don't know James expecto go is
the uh the content creator who was there
at the first gameplay showcase
it did not come through well on stream
however I interviewed James two weeks
ago on the channel here
if you guys go back in the in the lives
you can find it which by the way
if you ever go back trying to find the
live streams YouTube has kind of changed
up how this behaves let me show you guys
this
so it now it doesn't show up here
so like if you go to my videos it
doesn't show up there that is only
pre-made videos that's it
home it will show up on home because I
have a category down here for past live
streams so now there's a separate tab
right here so if you're on our page here
and you go live that is where you can
see all of the previous live streams
which by the way what do you guys think
about the new thumbnail design let me
know leave me leave me a comment and let
me know if you like the new one better
or the old one I kind of I made up this
little logo here I thought this might be
fun for live streams what I don't like
is I feel like these are a little too
small anyway I digress I don't want to
go down the YouTube thumbnail rabbit
hole right now
don't want to go down that rabbit hole
at this point
but go back if you didn't see that watch
that interview with James and he talks
about one of the things that jumped out
to him
is the sound design the NPC chatter
and I thought that was such a good point
and such a good valuable Insight from
him being somebody actually in the room
because we did not get that on the live
stream
and audio mixing is hard so it's like I
I know the people doing the audio mixing
on that they had a tough job because
they they had to balance you know what
Chandler and what the panel are talking
about then they want to get some music
in there as well but then you also have
the NPC chatter going on too
there is a scene in my video that I just
posted today where someone on Twitter
actually went there and broke down a
specific scene and you can hear Nat's
eye and um Sebastian having a
conversation in the background
so and James comment and said there's a
lot of that there's a ton of sound
effects so I think that is I think we
did not get a good impression of it but
I think it's going to be in the game for
sure for sure for sure for sure
looks like some people are heading out
good night guys thank you all so much
for being here
thank you for being here
don't like change I know right
have a good one Professor Baxter have a
good one thank you for coming thank you
for hanging out
all right guys we have just crossed the
three hour mark which I'm TR I'm trying
to get down to two and a half for these
things man trying to get down to two and
a half but we just like we just get in a
Zone you know we're just getting a Zone
we start flowing it's almost 11 p.m my
time I gotta start getting ready for bed
but it's been fun guys
it's been super fun
we're gonna wrap it up there uh I need
to look through
so my uh schedule and my wife's schedule
around the holidays is crazy and next
week guys next week we will officially
be in the month of December so I'm
taking off some work some work you tell
it's been three hours I'm taking some
time off of work near the end of
December there's a couple of days in
there where I've got to uh I'll just be
home alone with the kids a couple days
there
so I need to figure out my streaming
schedule and if we're going to be on
Tuesdays or not
I think like just glancing at it don't
hold me to this but just glancing I
think we'll be able to stick to Tuesdays
trying to see if I'm gonna be having any
travel in there I might be traveling
to my parents
some point closer to New Year's
but yeah we'll just we'll just play it
by ear and see also I am putting
together some plans for a big
Christmas
Extravaganza giveaway stream
I'm trying to organize the logistics of
it now
you guys have been so incredible to me
this year and so I just want to give
back to you guys in some
some small way
whatever small way that I can get back I
want to try and get back to you guys
so I'm putting that together now I don't
know the dates on that yet but as soon
as I have the dates on it I'll let you
know
but yeah man last November stream you
guys and then we're gonna be then we're
gonna start saying like
I mean we basically
this is what really put things into
perspective in terms of how close we are
for Hogwarts Legacy guys
so Benjamin snow fellow Hogwarts Legacy
Creator said he he averages about one
video per week
so let's just start with next week if he
puts out a video next week that would be
one two three four
five
six seven eight nine
that means he has nine videos left until
the launch of the game
that is mind-blowing
that is mind-blowing
nine videos left like I'm just I'm
getting to the point now now I usually
do two a week
but I am like I'm starting to have to
think about dude what do I want to make
sure we cover
what do I want to make sure I I hit on
before the release of the game
because
we're we're about there man we are about
there
Noob with a super chat jumping in right
there have a good night everyone in
retro maybe need another drink to stay
hydrated that's right we are haven't
quite finished it yet tonight
foreign
is good enough for giving back I
appreciate that JP appreciate it I gotta
do something more though gotta do
something more
I want you guys to have um
man they're just some of my favorite
streams there are a lot of big streamers
who do like these charity streams and
these big giveaway streams and they're
I don't know how big we're gonna be able
to go I'm gonna have to sit down and
look at everything and figure it all out
but I just I really want to get back to
you guys in some way man I really do
so I'm gonna see what we can do
um the also this is also a really
complicated I I would I would love to
buy a bunch of physical items
collection Edition items anyone
and give away stuff like that but we
have such a global audience here
that I think shipping would just be
and and I always I get frustrated when
contests they're like us only like we
could do that we could go the us only
route but so many of you guys aren't in
the US and so I wouldn't want people to
be excluded outside of the us because we
have I mean obviously people in here
trying to think of all the places I've
seen people from I've seen Brazil
obviously the UK I've seen Germany
Canada U.S of course
um did I say Australia I've seen people
from Australia we had somebody from
Spain in here one night
um
it's just like
it's amazing how global
I mean the Harry Potter audience
obviously but then the Hogwarts Legacy
audience and then the Retro record tour
audience all ye members of house wreck
and tour
all ye members
was there Japan last week
right it's crazy so I want to do
something that anybody
at least have some things that anybody
would be eligible to win but then you
get to the point where it's like yeah
well gift cards
so say what can I do
that's more fun than gift cards the gift
cards are nice too like you know some
people a lot of you in the Stream are so
very generous with the super chats with
the donations the gifted memberships all
that I appreciate that and yet I also
recognize there are a lot of people out
there struggling
a lot of people who don't have the money
to donate and so this would be a way for
me to help some of those people out you
know
to people who really need a win like
maybe maybe they win a 25 gift card and
it's going to let them buy their their
kid another another present that they
wouldn't have been able to buy otherwise
you know so I I do think about stuff
like that too on the surface you know
sometimes gift cards like ah that
doesn't seem like a lot of fun
but somebody it could be a huge win and
so that's what I I keep reminding myself
of
UK only nah nah we're not gonna do that
oh thank you Chris huff and puff thank
you give away future game copy signed by
me I don't think people would want would
you want my signature to besmirch the
Hogwarts Legacy box art
I would be incredibly humbled for anyone
who says yes but I I feel like most
people are gonna be like uh no
no
I would not
dude just taking a look at this uh one
more time
I'm not like a huge fan of Steel books
but I gotta say I dig the art style on
that
oh my gosh noobs like I would love that
Gabe says yes Alicia says really how
would I say would I sign it as retro or
not until I get on TV like like James I
like that
I think I would have to sign as retro
record tour
if I signed it as Jonathan you guys
would be like who the heck is this
who is this
oh man see I could just ramble and chat
with you guys all night all right I'm
gonna cut it that's gonna be it for me
I think there's gonna be one more
Hogwarts Legacy video hitting this week
my next big one that I'm working on is
gonna be the full combat breakdown I
don't know if that one will be this week
or not
but that one's gonna be hitting very
soon very soon I would say within the
next two weeks hopefully I can get that
one out oh yeah our final
the final verdict Nico is just
dying to know here
our top chatter
of the Stream
Chris huff and puff hangs on
to the title
congratulations Chris huff and puff
we had I don't know how accurate this is
if this is updated in real time or not
we had
1954 comments 10 commands only seven
timeouts okay you guys were acting like
as afraid people were getting timed out
left and right
oh goodness all right guys hey we
accomplished a lot in the Stream we did
a God of War unboxing replay Squad if
you missed it check that out go back and
watch it it was pretty funny the Box
almost
took up too much space and I didn't have
enough room back here to open it we
talked about all the latest Hogwarts
Legacy news we watched through the ASMR
video we talked about whether or not
Hogwarts Legacy is going to win the most
anticipated
game at the Video Game Awards
and then we talked a lot about Hogwarts
Legacy all your questions comments
concerns
but that's going to be it for tonight
that's gonna be it for tonight thank you
all so much for being here
and I'll talk to you again soon
foreign